we are back from the 4th of July holiday
and you know I made a mistake on Friday
I said we were going to be back on
Monday and then immediately was
corrected after the show ended I was
like okay uh you know what the thing is
you you will not be able to get guests
on July 3rd or 4th because nobody's
going to want to travel right before the
fourth and nobody wants to do a late
night show on the fourth when there's
fireworks going off and people have
gotten out of work and there's Burgers
so I was like let's just take the
opportunity and celebrate America but
there's a lot of news so they found
cocaine at the White House in the West
Wing where the Oval Office is Joe
Biden's laughing about it and I'm just
look
they're trying to make it seem like it
might have been a tourist or something
you're not getting cocaine in the White
House past security if you're just a
tourist so of course everybody's
suggesting maybe Hunter Biden maybe
maybe I honestly think it's probably
somebody with high enough clearance
where they're not being stopped by
security but we'll talk about this we'll
get into uh uh that news we've got some
news from the past week Rhonda Sanders
when he did that when the defense
campaign posted that ad
about Trump being uh pro-lgbt or
whatever DeSantis is actually getting a
lot of flack for this and peaky blinders
that's what's called right peaky
blinders yeah that's the show they've
they've come out and publicly denounced
the Santa's campaign over this ad that
DeSantis campaign didn't even make they
just reposted but I think this one's
particularly particularly interesting
and then we got a bunch of other news
but one big story couple there's a Bud
Light bottling plant is shutting down
two plants actually 645 employees are
being laid off because Bud Light sales
have tanked so much they they can't
handle the volume anymore so wow and we
definitely got to talk about sound of
Freedom if you guys haven't seen it I
really do recommend it's an amazing
movie it's about trafficking Jim Jim
Caviezel uh we went and saw it last
night so we'll talk about that and uh
it's rivaling Indiana Jones it was
released on a Tuesday not for the
weekend but for Tuesday sound of freedom
is just short of Indiana Jones take so
that's actually quite amazing I'm really
impressed with that I'm really excited
so we'll get into all that before we do
my friends head over to castbrew.com and
buy our coffee join the cast Brew Coffee
Club buy our coffee really I really
gotta say I think it's the best coffee
I've ever had and that's easy for me to
say because you know we formulated it we
put the roast together and found what we
thought was the best and we're hoping
that you think it's the best as well
purchase rise with Roberto Jr light
roast or Appalachian night Star Gross
they they come in either ground or whole
bean and you can join the cast Brew
Coffee Club get three bags every single
month we're sponsoring ourselves with
their support buying our coffee you'll
help keep the show going and help us
expand into the physical space as we
build out our coffee shops for physical
locations we're working on it it's a lot
of work to be done it's not the easiest
thing in the world but uh we're getting
there don't forget to also head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member get access to our Discord server
where you can hang out with like-minded
people and actually call into our
members only after show we'll have one
of those for you tonight just at 10 p.m
on the live show on YouTube wraps up and
you can actually submit questions and
call in and talk to us it'll be a lot of
fun so smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and so much more is Matt Brainerd
glad to be back thanks for having me Tim
absolutely uh who are you what do you do
oh I'm just a mere Community organizer
and uh civil rights organizer fighting
with a good fight for the January 6th
prisoners fighting to get election
Integrity restored in the country and on
the side helping out campaigns here and
there right on we got philibati hanging
out hello everyone I am Phil Levante
lead singer of All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
I swear that was not my cocaine at the
White House search
uh sorry uh hi are you in Crossland and
I do not do cocaine I have done cocaine
in the past I will admit but I may not
do that stuff but I imagine you're a
mushrooms guy way better it's way I
think if you do it in the right dosage
it's really when you talk about drugs
you want to talk about dosage isn't
Nixon that created this whole drugs
thing and put them all into this basket
of like yeah forever chemicals crocodile
works great if you microdose it hear
that stuff no no none of that stuff yeah
none of that it's really it's really sad
to see like the the all over West
Virginia they have these like emergency
treatment things for the drugs and how
it's really damaged to everybody oh
crocodile and people their flesh no we
don't we'll let's talk let's talk about
Hunter Biden's problem yeah because
other chemicals they call them drugs and
they're nowhere near as dangerous so
let's just move on when I heard the
story my mind immediately went to the
disparity of Justice in this country how
many people are sitting in prison right
now because the exact same amount of
cocaine was found somewhere near them in
their car in their home and when it
comes to the White House oh they're just
laughing about it they're making jokes
there's a video that circulates of Joe
bidening like if they are found within
this much crack
prison and it's like the same amount and
then it shows Hunter with like rocks
we'll get into the news let's introduce
our man over here to the right yeah I'm
just laughing about that this is pretty
funny yeah it's good news now like I
said like Trump's comes where uh Trump's
White House had Coke all over the place
you know pretty openly it's that Diet
Coke though it's not the same thing so
all right anyways let's get to it here's
the first store we got it from
timcast.com cocaine found in the White
House prompts evacuation if it's the old
executive office building it's likely
staffed tweeted Ari Fleischer if it's
the Mansion it's likely Hunter is
amazing the White House was evacuated
around 8 45 pm on July 3rd after the
substance was discovered by members of
the secret service uniform division
during a routine patrol of the building
the item was sent for further evaluation
and an investigation into the cause and
manner of how it entered the White
House's pending the Secret Service said
in a subsequent statement per NPR the
agency will review surveillance footage
and visitor logs as part of its
investigation the location of where the
cocaine was discovered has become a
point of controversy and as your reports
claim the drugs were discovered in the
ground floor library of the presidential
residence The Washington Post quoted a
dispatch from DC's Department of
hazardous materials team in which a
firefighter stated we have a yellow bar
saying cocaine hydrochloride yeah I saw
this story over the weekend it was like
Hazmat situation and uh
remember we were talking to but they're
like oh that sounds like something's
actually happening turns out it was
cocaine and now they're saying it was in
The West Wing so it's kind of like
either way no matter where it was look
the highest probability is Hunter Biden
hands down no question and they've said
cocaine but I'm wondering could it have
been crack or something you know the
timcast article from Hannah Claire
mentions his uh crack cocaine addiction
we have an update on the story Biden
laughs off White House cocaine Scandal
and refuses to answer reporter's
questions while press secretary Karine
Jean-Pierre suggests drugs found in
Westing belong to a visitor
I'm sure they did
this is the first time someone's claimed
to have done drugs in the white house I
think Willie Nelson and Snoop Dogg
claimed they did I was talking about
this earlier and I was thinking about it
and I could be wrong but my view of this
whole thing is the founding fathers
probably did a ton of drugs in the white
house then there was probably a period
from like the early 1900s to like the
70s where there were no drugs in the
white house and then you started getting
probably a lot more drugs in the white
house after that I think or John Kennedy
I think Mike I bet he partied hard he
would have like well yeah that's true
and she was like she did a ton of drugs
you know I I don't know because I
actually had a good friend of mine who
worked with me on the Trump campaign in
16 she worked very very hard and because
of that she earned a White House job
under President Trump however she tested
positive for smoking weed and that was
yanked no way not getting in here so the
the Stan I don't know what the standards
are for this white house but I know
historically that has not been tolerated
and there's dude
if someone came to me and said Bill
Clinton did not do drugs in the white
house I would bust out laughing
to your point like if you're going to be
in the Oval Office and stuff like that
even if you're some kind of Clerk or
something like that you have you have to
have some kind of clearance and if you
have any kind of drug history or if you
lie on the polygraph test then you can't
get a clearance so it makes sense that
there would be you know issues with like
your average person if you're someone
higher up like if you're a chief of
staff or if you're PR the president or
if you're you know someone like that I
imagine you could probably get the
Secret Service to overlook or ignore or
something like that but if it's just
your average
like one of the lower tier people that
actually has to work for the president
or in the office I imagine they're
getting tested and you know because they
have to have a clearance it's got to be
somebody who doesn't have to go through
security yeah or someone that has enough
clout where if they go through security
security can't be like yo you know weird
yeah because not only would I don't look
you could Secret Service Overlook it
they might also cover it up no be like
hey terrorism everyone look out we gotta
mask up this could be dangerous like uh
really it's cocaine nobody
who has to go through security is
bringing cocaine to the White House
I I just
and what what level of staff member has
to go through security and would be like
I've got clout and I have to go to
security and they're going to find out I
have this but they can't do anything no
way I bet there's a lot more than we
realize just no it's just that they're
like addicted and they're like I'm not
doing another day without it kind of
mentality like how to surveillance but
how does surveillance not catch it
because you know they the Discord leaker
of all those Secrets they found him real
fast but for some reason they can't
immediately figure out who dropped it in
a certain room like there's parts of the
White House that are not monitored where
the story is is this is where tourists
are allowed so there are parts of the
White House where tourists can go
and is not monitored does anyone really
buy that yeah I bet I think they they
know I'm pretty confident they know
exactly whose that belongs to Good Luck
figuring out and and I'm gonna say this
they have surveillance all over that
building the idea that they don't do not
is insane we know they do we have they
have men on the roof when you when you
when you go and visit the White House
you can see there's guys up there okay
they're watching you and they're armed
and they've got sniper rifles yes they
do so if you're gonna try and tell me
they don't have surveillance in that
building that is under so I'm going to
say this
that suggests they know who did it are
covering it up therefore it was Hunter
Biden I I mean I mean to say this let's
clarify I'm not saying I really believe
it was Hunter I don't know I'm just
saying
until they actually come out and say
whose it was I am just going to say it
was Hunter because you know Occam's
razor you gotta you gotta you got a
crack addict drug addict guy with access
to the White House to the degree he will
not be stopped by security they know who
he is the president's son
as probably his
you know whether it's Hunter Biden or
somebody else what we do know for a fact
is there's two tears of Justice just
like Hunter Biden got treated very
gently with his prosecution for his
crimes that other people are suffering
badly for losing their families in jail
for
possession of cocaine in a place like
that
anybody else even in your house in your
car you park your car next to the White
House and they find that in you in your
car you are you're in a world of pain
but the White House one of the protected
people two-tier Justice we're just gonna
laugh it off yep
Jack besobic said he thought there's
actually a three-tier justices and
there's a little bit of an aside but
that there's the protected class there's
the plebes the regular people like all
everyone else you know and then there's
the persecuted class which is like a
unique class like Julian Assange or at
the moment Donald Trump or j6ers exactly
uh I guess so yeah where it's like it
doesn't really matter what you've done
they wanna this just it's personal kind
of he's a class of people there's the
persecuted the protected and then the we
don't care that we don't care people can
get scooped up and pushed around
sometimes and sometimes they get ignored
there might be someone who committed a
crime and they're like I don't know
about this whatever then you have the
protected the political Elites and their
cronies and their followers and
worshipers and then you of course have
the persecuted the people like Jay like
the the woman in Alaska's home was rated
because she looked like a woman who went
in the Capitol building
that's crazy you know I actually went to
the DC Gulag I was allowed in to visit a
prisoner and just the fact just going in
was completely dehumanized if you ever
want to come in I can get you in too but
I went there to meet a guy named William
kressman this is the exact this is a
great example of what Jack was talking
about this guy has not been charged with
any violence he's a military veteran
he's not even charged with conspiracy
you're organizing anything it's just a
guy who showed up he was arrested in
January of 2021.
he still doesn't have a trial date wow
and they have denied him his psychiatric
medicine
they have trash he tries to keep
journals and they just come through and
throw all his papers away uh he's not
been given he has two daughters that he
had not seen for all for those two years
plus two young daughters and he was
finally going to get to see them the
week after I was in to visit him and
that is just whatever the wildest thing
in the world they wanted to accuse him
of that they might even charge him with
he would have already had time serve but
they're keeping him in there in dire
conditions still not a trial date
military veteran not charged with any
violence
because they can because because not of
what he did but because of what he
believed and that's a great example of
what Jack busovic's talking about is
this the indefinite detention because of
the clause and like what the ndaa I
think no it's worse this is unjustified
constitutional violations
speedy trial man it's right it's right
there so I mean where are we at is
someone going to file a lawsuit or
something to get some movement on this
you know he's been doing his best his
lawyer's been doing his best but they
just keep blowing not like I said not
even a trial date not even bail he has
he's a clean record he's a military
veteran he fought for this country
overseas and you know the only thing
that I've been look I've been doing a
lot of things on this field the last
thing we have decided is that the only
person who's really going to be able to
make an effect on this is the next
president so we've launched a project
called the j6 question we're paying a
thousand dollars to anybody who'll ask
one of our presidential candidates what
they're going to do for the j6 prisoners
and I'm very happy to say that today we
actually cut our first check for a
thousand dollars we announced the
project two weeks ago somebody asked
Asia Hutchinson got it on video we've
been presenting it so the only way the
only person who can really fix this is
the next president so we're going to get
them on the record now so voters can be
informed going to The Ballot Box in
terms of how these people are going to
handle what I believe is the greatest
civil rights violation of our day
how many people are in prison right now
from January 6. oh we've got 141 in fact
there were 42 people just rested last
month and the doj has plans for another
thousand to be arrested there are a lot
of them that are still in jail without a
trial date without any opportunity for
bail and they're just hanging out there
how many people have been let go or have
been released uh quite a few quite a few
hundred the thing is and this is the
most disgusting part of it to me is that
the department of Justice's attitude is
that you might be able to beat the
charges but you can't beat the ride and
you can't afford it so a lot of people
are just taking a plea agreement to just
get out of it even though they're not
guilty and in fact I'm really kept
admire William kressman because he was
offered a plea agreement he had to do
two things he had to agree to the two
lesser charges and he had to condemn
president Trump why he say that
President Trump was the one that made
him do it I said that's just not true
and I'm not going to admit to something
that isn't true so he has put himself
through this like a martyr and I cannot
wait for the day that he gets out and
that he can tell his story publicly
because it's that that was to ask you
have to condemn president Trump and you
have to plead to these other charges I'm
not guilty of any of it dude that's that
like that Chinese version I don't want
to blame the Chinese but that weird like
communism yeah what's that that tactic
where they make you they come in and
they make you say things that you know
aren't true to break you and then
they're like re-education kind of
mentality that's that's a I've never
heard of that in the United States
before this is the first time maybe
maybe they did to the Japanese
internment prisoners in during World War
well what they want to do is they're
using these people as Pawns in hopes
that they turn on President Trump
because if they say oh I did it because
president Trump told me that makes it
easier for them the prosecution to go
after president Trump say hey we got all
these people telling them that you did
this because haven't people already done
that though yeah there are a handful of
people who are like oh it was Trump's
fault if but remember that's under
severe duress right because they're
getting a deal because of it a lot of
people think that Trump didn't hasn't
done enough to help those people what
could he do I don't know what do you get
that Vibe what do you think he could do
or I don't know what he's done behind
the scenes but what I do know is the
only person can really do anything
is the next president if that's the only
body the only person who's got any
ability to move this and uh look my take
on it is that they should be given
blanket pardons especially because the
vast majority of these people have not
been charged with violence you think
it's the next president so like for two
years these people are just screwed like
Biden do you think there's anything like
a little a little less than two years
like a year and a half
right so he told the guy when you went
in what was the guy's name again that
you William Cressman and look I uh we
have a j6 database at look ahead America
look at america.org j6 we have the most
comprehensive database of everybody
that's been charged and it tells you
whether they're arrested or anything
like that so if you want to help William
Cressman you can look him up there and
you know send his attorneys some money
on his gifts and go
um but we have done the good thing is
the Public's now on our side because the
plurality of people agree that these
people are in fact political prisoners
but the Biden Administration does not
care and the FBI who are persecuting
these people in the doj they do not care
because there's no accountability
there's nothing you can do to stop them
other than
make an informed decision about the next
president the fear look uh you know
people people love it when I say the the
magic words Civil War
but let's think about where we're at at
the very least we it may be a Bleeding
Kansas type phase
you know before and maybe I'm wrong uh
in the 1820s there was talk of Civil War
over the issue of slavery economics and
things around this and it wasn't until
40 some odd years later that war
actually broke out but what a point
where federal law enforcement
has
I I don't think detained is even the
right word renditioned people without
charge or trial
that's it the the Constitution is Swiss
cheese the idea that the the doj can
take people and hold them now more than
two years later
often in solitary which is torture
without charge or trial
I come on it's insane you know Iran only
held up held our hostages for 444 days
these people have been in over for 800
still waiting on a trial date my guess
is that the administration feels like if
they're all let out and pardoned that
Trump that they think Trump will
actually create a revolution and they
think that those people will be the foot
soldiers well and that's like such a
dumb like I think it's just intimidating
other people I really think that the the
reason that the the people that are you
know still in prison and for the the j6
riot and stuff is just because they want
the rest of America to be like well you
know they don't they're not gonna
observe your or or respect your rights
they're going to hold you in violation
of you know the the Fifth Amendment your
your right to a speedy trial and stuff
they're gonna they're they're just gonna
run roughshod over the Constitution if
the if the federal government feels it's
acceptable to kill a U.S citizen because
they have a suspicion that they're you
know a terrorist or because they don't
like some of the things that they were
saying then I don't think that it's it's
ridiculous to think that the government
wants to use its power to intimidate
other Americans you know yeah I fully
agree with that man it's who's gonna
they don't want anyone to Riot they
don't want anyone to even protest at the
White House I don't think they want
anyone near it I don't know about anyone
they just don't want the right to
because if it was the left they would
let it if it was if it was antifa they
they I mean there's history there is a
there's a past history
demonstrably that they will not arrest
people on the left in the same manner
and with the same Vigor and with the
same malice that they arrest people on
the right there were people rioting in
all over uh Washington DC which is the
29th of uh May of 2000 or whatever or
2020 what was the when they I was it May
29th I think I think 29th but the people
I I I I talk about this a lot the reason
why blackstone's formulation was so
important to the reason why we have the
right to a speedy trial innocent until
proven guilty
it's the founding fathers believed that
if people could be uh held criminally uh
in in prison or jail even if they were
innocent there would be no incentive to
be a good citizen if at any point you
could be arrested this is why it's
better that 10 guilty persons Escape
than one is an innocent person suffer
because if people believe if I'm truly a
good person the system will protect me
now we can see the inversion of that
yeah that's why this is they don't care
but here's the important point
if people start to believe and
unfortunately it is true that no matter
what you do
the byte Administration the cult these
evil depraved people are going to use
the way to force against you there is no
incentive to negotiate the point is yes
this is the behavior that like any other
Domino collapse leads to governmental
collapse you can see it in all these
other countries what happens in Syria
you get protesters the the the the the
Assad uh
regime whatever you want to call it says
we are going to stop these people
creating a backlash Occupy Wall Street
best example
about a thousand thousand people are
marching down the street Anthony bologna
the cop walks up to three random women
who were not a part of the March and
pepper sprays them because they were
yelling the video goes viral the fastest
viral video in history at that point 1.2
million views in less than a day in like
12 hours
igniting Occupy Wall Street across the
country
when law enforcement uses heavy-handed
tactics it is a spark on kindling and
what scares me about what we're seeing
with the bite Administration and the
j6ers is that it's sending a message to
people not to be scared of them but that
they are illegitimate they will not
follow the rule of law they will not
give you a fair trial therefore there is
no system by which you were involved it
is no different than a group of muggers
beating you mercilessly in the street
there's no Rhyme or Reason other than
they want to assert power over you
this is one more domino falling all over
towards a potential Civil War in this
country yeah you know this is why I use
the word dumb when I talked about these
tactics of like they're afraid these
people will become Trump's foot soldiers
if they're all let out and pardoned the
back the problem is you're creating the
problem that you're afraid of by
incarcerating them against their without
a trial or without even a charge because
it's radicalizing them in prison and
when they come out their families will
remember and their friends will remember
and you're radicalizing an entire
population and an entire 50 years worth
of people by by violating their
constitutional rights you need to trust
the populace I maybe being in the
government is not a realm of trust you
know you're afraid and you're always on
the defensive perhaps I don't well
that's part of why I don't run history
shows that there's a silver line to this
because how many of the great leaders
who've done wonderful things for their
country at some point in their early
life were political prisoners like
Mandela or Martin Luther King or in
India vir savakar that's a pattern
throughout history of great positive
revolutionary leaders at some point
crossed a civil disobedience line across
the administration and ended up in
prison and that you can see that in
countries all over the world I don't
think we're quite at Civil War yet and
I'm gonna because here's here's the real
here's the problem as I see it as a
community organizer somebody that does
voter registration and voter turnout in
the Georgia Senate runoff
in the urban counties the progressive
Urban counties turnout was in the mid
80s
in the rural counties where I think at
least as many voters are turnout was in
the mid 50s and there you have the
outcome of the election if turnout in
those rural counties was anywhere close
to the urban areas
they those people would have a louder
voice but unfortunately they do not turn
out they are not part of the ballot
harvesting machine they're not part of
the voting culture and that's where I'm
putting my effort to try to change I'm I
wouldn't do too well in a civil war I've
got terrible Vision but in in terms of
community organizing and in elections I
think it's there if we just can if we
just have to seize it and you know our
constituency is disaffected patriotic
Americans Rural and blue-collar
backgrounds and the best example of
somebody like this from history
is Dorothy from Wizard of Oz from a poor
background probably her family didn't
own that farm uh they were at the whims
of much more powerful forces in the
economy and in the government and she
was just blown off with a tornado to
some foreign land where she had
absolutely no control and no power but
she realized by the end she had the
power all along in her ruby slippers and
she just needed to tap them together and
stay home sweet home if we can just get
our people in the same way to recognize
if they cast those ballots an informed
ballot and get engaged with the process
they can solve their problems how do you
feel about voting machines like I'm very
concerned about proprietary voting
machines where we can't see the code so
we don't know if they're flipping vote
tallies in the background how do you
foresee a solution to at least create
transparency so that we know for sure
that it's giving us accurate vote
tallies so I have documented cases where
the voting machines made a mistake and
there was a a county that where this
happened it was caught and it was fixed
but what I think is the solution long
term is to insist on open source voting
equipment you know hand count that's
technically open source and even if you
don't believe because you know all these
Democrats and leftists were saying
before 2020 that oh I see these machines
changing votes right in front of my eyes
Kamala Harris said that herself there's
a documentary on HBO now they're all
denying it but even if you don't believe
that there's a lot of good reasons to
switch to open source voting equipment
which is that it's a hell of a lot
cheaper it's like half the cost and when
you get proprietary equipment you're
locked into that company maintaining it
fixing it updating it forever and that
gets very expensive it's a monopoly
whereas if it's open source you can have
an in-state tech company you can create
in-state jobs to maintain it and update
it and I'll tell you it's really more of
a republican issue now but there was a
democrat in Congress who is a scientist
and he he actually proposed a law
manding that all voting equipment be
open source so even in places like
California we're making progress on that
front and I honestly I I have not seen
any evidence of machines intentionally
changing the outcome of a result of a
vote and I've seen a lot of evidence in
the contrary but it's really about
restoring Trust of the public they need
to believe it they need to have a Matt
Brainerd walk in and see oh yes these
machines are correct the code is right
it's doing what it says it can do to
restore their trust in the voting system
and I think that's why so many on the
left oppose it is because they don't
want the trust restored because they
want people discouraged from voting
Let's uh let's jump into this next story
I do want to come back to the voting
stuff but I want to work through some of
these camp this campaign news we have
the story from NBC News peaky blinders
and Cillian Murphy denounce homophobic
video shared by DeSantis campaign the
video uses footage from various films
shows and media Outlets to depict the
Florida governor taking extreme
anti-lgbtq positions and we have this
tweet it says on behalf of the partners
of peaky blinders Stephen Knight Cillian
Murphy Karen mandebok Productions tiger
aspect Productions and bana J writes we
confirm the footage of Tommy Shelby's
character used within the video posted
by Rhonda sent us a campaign was
obtained without permission or official
license we do not support nor endorse
the video's narrative and strongly
disapprove of the use of the content in
this manner and then we also have this
from the hill Republican lgbtq group
blast DeSantis over homophobic campaign
video I don't know if they actually post
it but you guys might remember this we
talked about it last week
I thought it was cringe I don't know did
you see this video man I saw it where
it's like Trump with the LG with the
pride flag and he's and he's saying you
know like we're gonna protect our lgbtq
supporter or LGBT supporters and then it
starts showing all these news clippings
of Ron DeSantis you know rejecting a lot
of the more modern woke stuff my take on
it was it's absurd to conflate Donald
Trump saying the the typical or the more
traditional Live and Let Live position
with the modern woke grooming position
like Trump is not supporting grooming
and the stuff that the Santa is going
after now that we support is stopping
the exploitation of children to conflate
those two things to make it seem like
Trump supported grooming today is
completely wrong but it's resulted in a
major backlash when I'm seeing on
Twitter this has been happening for for
the past week or so we've been out and
now even peaky blinders coming out and
attacking him over it I'm not surprised
the media and Hollywood or whatever
would come after him but even
conservatives are criticizing him for
this you know uh I sort of put on my
political consultant hat with this one
and this is just one other case of
desantis's Staff screwing up his chances
oh yeah and this it's no it wasn't Ronda
stands that went to the account and
retweeted it now look outside groups
create edgy weird videos to support
their candidate all the time and that's
what happened here some edgy outside
group created this but then somebody who
has access to the campaign account saw
that and they thought oh let's let's
retweet this one because then it made
something it was an outside group that
had distance from the campaign maybe
maybe got a few voters their way or made
people ask questions how committed is
Trump to the anti-groomer agenda and
then they totally stepped in it by reach
and basically by retweet they took
ownership of the video and look I run in
the same circles of people that work for
DeSantis and all the other campaigns and
inside the complaints about his staff
screwing up his campaign have been
persistent and growing louder going back
months and months and here's the problem
is that you when you're a governor of a
state and you you win a seat by a large
margin because you're a great Governor
she is and your candidate your opponent
is terrible everybody in the staff that
thinks they're the ones that earned you
that 19 Point Victory and in terms of
expanding from a governor's race to a
national race which is from t-ball to to
Major League Baseball
you have to expand that Circle of trust
and what he's done is he's taken a team
that didn't really do a lot to get him
through governor's race and now oh now
we're running a presidential campaign
and that he has to learn to expand his
circle of trust to get people who are
not going to allow bonehead mistakes
like that to happen and because look
this there's a lot of stuff going on
there's been
tremendously detrimental to his campaign
and it just comes down to staff and I
look it's his it's his steps his his
campaign press team
have been rolling around in it like
crazy picking fights with a women's
group in New Hampshire because they
dealt with they double schedule an event
New Hampshire with the most powerful
women Republican women's group in the
state everyone's saying oh we're sorry
we'll uh move it to a different date or
a different time or something like they
said oh we'll pick a fight with these
guys what kind of fight what'd they do
public a public fight like verbal on
Twitter yeah like that kind of fight
which it's just there and there's stuff
happening behind the scenes I can't
really see share them aware of but I'll
give you one really good example okay
so there's this guy this congressman
from Florida who us uh Greg stoop who uh
was not sure who he was going to endure
he had to endorse Trump yet like most of
his colleagues from Florida right and uh
he's up in the air right and he had he
got a phone call
a member of desantis's Staff called him
to say hey can you hold off endorsing
president Trump because we'd like to get
your endorsement
both of you know the problem with that
right
a staff member calling a member of
Congress to back not the governor a
staff member this is a guy this is
interesting because this guy he had an
accident he fell off a ladder in
December or something he badly injured
himself the first person to call him in
the emergency room Trump yes and I've
got so many friends who are like Mitch
they're like mid to clear low tier
influencers say something cool about
President Trump guess what they get a
FedEx with the Tweet with his signature
on it say keep up the great work yeah
like all candidates have their flaws but
it it's just really troubling to see
these repeated mistakes and Trump's team
they're all on top of some things you
know they're they're great at these
Trump is the guy I saw I I went to his
rallies in 2015 and 16. when the rally
was over he'd walk up to the the front
of the stage the barricades and he would
just hang out and shake hands and just
talk to whoever was there he knows
people
calling that guy if they're getting hurt
he's like a person it's like an
authentic thing to do DeSantis has been
plastic
the whole time he's surrounded his press
people are miserably bad and I want to
show you this real quick uh so put it
put a pin in that thought Phil predict
it now has Ron at 24 cents he was
actually rivaling Trump and at some
point I think he was above Trump now
he's he's gone
it's it's gone Matt do you think that
because as far as I can tell the the
strategy that the Santos has is to
attack Trump from the right do you think
that that's a
a winning strategy
I'm not sure that that is his strategy I
think it's been different things at
different times which is part of the
part of the problem look it was going to
be an uphill battle to begin with and
I I think it was a little bit unexpected
was that the indictments would actually
and first I could see this I'm sure
everyone at this table could see this
but the indictments were actually very
helpful to consolidating the base to
Trump and they did something else is
they sucked all the oxygen out of the
air for all the other candidates right
plus with the fact that you've got all
these other candidates coming in if it
was a monomy model it might be a
different story because I think what
DeSantis value proposition is that I'm
just as conservative not more
conservative but I can actually deliver
on what I say because they'll point out
to you know things that Trump couldn't
quite get done do you feel like Trump's
because I feel like Trump's strength
wasn't in that he was particularly
conservative his strength was that he
would lit take the fight to the left so
Trump didn't have to be like you know he
was he was friendly to LGBT uh issues
and stuff like that um and he didn't
really come from the conservative
especially the religious conservative I
mean everybody remembers the whole you
know the Bible is my favorite book of
the Bible you know that that exchange so
I don't feel like he was ever
particularly far to the right did you
feel like he was it I think that there
are issues where he was to the right of
the party on immigration he was by far
the most right-wing candidate in 2016
because
right before he went down that elevator
escalator he had read Ann coulter's book
on immigration and that fired him up and
that really put him on the map and uh
but I think the what he has over the
other candidates is that he's a known
quantity a lot of people think he was uh
is that the election in 2020 was rigged
or I I can say it now I guess some
people a lot of people think it was
stolen or rigged and uh you could always
say that but you just couldn't play
Trump saying oh yeah yeah but he um he
is authentic and he's got a level of
authenticity that is like when you read
his tweets when he was on Twitter and
now his tweets are still on Twitter
because they'll just take truth and
repost it on Twitter you read that and
you know he wrote it and you know nobody
nobody's got in his way it wasn't focus
group or anything like that
whereas some of these other candidates
they I think they just struggle a little
bit with the authenticity it's kind of
crazy watching uh
DeSantis is crashing and burning and it
really is his prestine because he has
done great work this uh this video I
pulled it up here's the video from the
tennis war room to wrap up pride month
let's hear from the politician who did
more than any other Republican to
celebrate it and they insult Trump for
what actually was good I know a lot of
people are not happy with the pride flag
and the current woke stuff but we've had
this conversation for years nine million
Obama voters switched to to the
Republican party and one of the big
issues was
Donald Trump was very much like these
are our Americans we're going to support
them this battle is over there is a big
difference between being like hey we
have no issue with you if you're gay and
there are people grooming children and
putting these weird books in schools
DeSantis is fighting against those weird
books he's playing against the grooming
stuff really really great work Donald
Trump was not in support of those things
back then the completely different
issues they're conflating them DeSantis
goes from you know on paper you have
this amazing track record in Florida to
a press team that is making him look
ridiculous I mean this video I said it
was cringe people were like I really
like it here let me play a little bit of
it for you guys
citizens but Caitlyn Jenner would walk
into Trump Tower and want to use the
bathroom you would be fine with her
using any bathroom she choose is that is
correct in the future 10 transgender
women compete in this universe yes make
America great again
okay it's basically showing
American Psycho and peaky blinders and
showing ad headlines like Rhonda Santa
signs Draconian anti-trans bathroom
known to law and
it this is really just not doing him any
favors like you were mentioning
attacking him from the right what is the
purpose of this video is it like so I'm
37. this video doesn't do it for me I'll
tell you because in 1996 there were a
lot of people outside the Trump campaign
that were creating really cool videos I
do this all the time my wife's yelling
at the TV right now
my golden times yeah in 2016 they were
creating these really cool third-party
videos that were like the meme Wars
right like the caterpillar uh videos and
they're really kind of cool and they had
a style they're trying to imitate that
and capture that whoever created this
video I mean clearly they've got some
editing talent and they're trying it's
in a it's got this motif of like a sort
of a 4chan pole Motif and vibe to it and
you almost think if you slow it down
enough you might see one of those um
the sort of a white nationalist Stars
those things wrote I can't remember what
it's called the Golden Sun thing
rotating in the back of the black sun
it's black sun it's like of that and I
feel like whoever created it was like
we're trying to get to these guys and
maybe they're not the most Savvy right
but somebody hit the retweet but button
on that campaign account and that is
that is uh they they can't they don't
belong to that job anymore we just find
out one person who needs to be fired
from the campaign were they fired from
this we probably wouldn't even know and
maybe they will be maybe they won't so
that that obviously has also had the
Deep fake thing when he posted the fake
photos of trump and fauci and it's still
up it's still up it's remarkable that
DeSantis I'm sorry
look man
I love his track record in Florida but
the man is incompetent if he cannot fire
his people after all of these blunders
the dude is not fit to be president and
it's like it's fine like if you wanted
to actually if the campaign wanted to
get a video like this out there to us to
undermine uh Trump among say a certain
portion of the right you have like an
outside group just sort of put it up
like it was originally like some weird
thing that they circulated through the
discords and the telegrams where those
people uh where those people live and
don't touch grass
but that there's you know and there's a
reason you know oftentimes you want to
have an indirect attack so you have it
somebody far away throw it at them and
then your hands are clean right this is
on an operational level a failure like
why didn't you psyop which is crazy
because you don't want candidates to be
psyopping each other but I mean he
didn't sigh up he put it on the DeSantis
account it was made by somebody else and
then they took the URL to the video and
tweeted it sorry to interrupt you were
saying yeah yeah but I mean maybe the
campaign did create it and they want to
get it out too but you don't you do
these things like I said I've been in
this field since the mid 90s that's why
I keep saying 96.
this is oh this is old school political
operation you have somebody else attack
you have some other source go after them
a distant proxy so you keep your hands
clean and they just Dove face first into
the mud with this one
look
a lot of people keep defending Ron they
say things like this is his campaign
it's not him blah blah blah at this
point the man has not taken the tweets
down or fired these people okay that
right there we talk about the problems
of bureaucracy these you know what I
love about the DeSantis people on
Twitter is they lie about what I've said
and if they're gonna play that game
where the Santa's post deep fakes then
they lie about what I'm saying they're
just trying to trick you into support as
a guy for whatever reason I don't know
one person was like Tim Poole thinks has
said that Trump will magically be
different this time around I was like I
never said that I said there's like a 55
chance Trump actually fires a bunch of
these people and that's the best we can
hope for if the probability between uh
if the probability is higher that Trump
will fire the bureaucrats over to sandus
you vote for Trump
DeSantis won't even fire his own bad
staff members and we're supposed to
believe he's going to end the Department
of Education or the IRS or something get
out of here with that not going to
happen in his defense it would cost you
with one thing and that is that it's a
long way to Iowa to New Hampshire to
South Carolina and a lot of these
candidates can make their course
correction so you never know what's
going to happen next
um I'm begging him
I am helping him I like his track record
in Florida I mean we we had on uh I'm
not going to say the names of these
people because they're duplicitous Liars
but we had a guest on culture War show
who tried to play in this game of like
name Apostles from descent policy from
DeSantis and no matter what I said she
just kept asking the same question as if
I didn't say anything because of course
they were clip farming and they intended
to lie the whole time but desantis's
policies based in Florida how he handled
kovid was good when it comes to the
books that they're being removed from
these schools good when it comes to
saying you can't have kids at these
events good these are good things
clearly in terms of culture War issues
we care about he is doing a good job
when it comes to attracting business and
new residents when it comes to taxes
he's doing a great job don't get me
wrong the Republican legislature in
Florida is probably doing a lot of the
heavy lifting but we like these things
because they matter to us then when it
comes to his terrible team
he can't handle it I am begging that a
Santa's campaign to fire these people so
that I can come out tomorrow and say I'm
on team DeSantis you know before not
gonna happen unless unless he does yeah
and the thing is too I've been all over
the country I've met with a lot of
people who we need to win over and a lot
of them they or they would be more happy
to vote for DeSantis than for Trump at
this point in time they would be they
they're they're you know for some reason
they just don't get along with Trump and
I think that look I actually met the
governor before he started running for
president I had a small chat with him
just one-on-one and he was great and I
think that he wrote a book recently was
published right and uh the courage to be
free I think and I read it I went from
beginning to end and it was a nice book
good biography but I don't think enough
of him was in it like he talked about
his whole baseball career right he
played baseball in high school and
college was very proud but I feel like
he needed to be more there's something
wrong with the book because it never
told me what position he played so
imagine talking about your first
question to play baseball but the book
maybe I missed it however before he ever
ran for congress after he got out of the
Navy he actually wrote a book that I am
sure he had to have written himself
because he didn't have a bunch of people
around him helping it was uh dreams of
our founding fathers there were only 100
or so copies published I got one of them
made a copy of it myself and I started
reading because I want to know these
guys the difference between those two
books the one that came out recently
that was probably had many editors and a
lot of help and the one he had to have
written himself that he he
self-published 120 copies of he would go
to GOP events and sell it at a card
table that book is brilliant that book
is it could be a textbook in a college
it is that level of understanding of our
founding fathers the principles of how
articulate it is I just I'd love to see
more of the Ron stance that wrote that
book than the new one but if he is so
weak that he's handed off these issues
to lesser uh skilled individuals than he
has shown he does not have what it takes
to be president he can he can have great
policy all he wants but just like just
like to him said if you can't get
elected if you can't then it doesn't
execution is everything it's not just
about getting elected it's about if he's
showing us that he has bad people
working in his campaign and he does
nothing about it what do you think is
going to happen when he's in government
he should be I mean he is in a position
where if he were if he were doing a
better job uh you know
um campaigning he should have you know a
significantly smaller gap between him
and Trump Trump's got a lot of downside
you know regardless of whether you you
support him or not there's a lot of
things people can criticize Trump for
Trump hired some bad people yeah he
definitely did but Trump has no problem
smack talking the people that he
eventually got rid of DeSantis is just
doing nothing and saying nothing
troubles that's right you know what
would be the real sign to everybody that
he's he's going to make a course
correction
he calls you and says I want to come on
your show because when you're in the
position he is right now you need to be
here you need to be talking to this
audience you need to be engaging and
that's up to the people who watch this
show right you know uh I'm just some
dude who complains about things on the
internet uh I I don't I I you know it's
like you know we've had people say like
Timmy should get Trump on you should get
this person on and I'm like dude none of
these people owe me anything if they
want to come on the show I'd love to
have them if Ron wanted to come on the
show we'd love to have them we wanted to
have them before and I think a
conversation like this but it would
greatly benefit him but here's the point
I think what we're seeing is that he is
incapable of a long-form free-flowing
conversation in this way he is too
surrounded by bad people who are not
allowing him to be an authentic
personality like Trump is I I disagree I
think he's capable of it if he just
undoes the tie and does the black collar
comes in and just sits down and Deals
because he's I know he has it in him
they just have to come in and don't
disagree what I'm what I'm saying is the
people who surround him are not allowing
him to do these things yeah we should
shoot some hoops come on down Ron let's
go play basketball on the skate park for
a little while and a couple hours before
the show get loose and then I don't know
if they don't have time for that that
could be that all the Time in the World
Turns The Campaign around and then he
does he reaches out he has this type of
conversation which I know he's capable
of and then his poll numbers go but I
believe the environment and fixing Earth
and stuff whether whether it is this
show or any other show if Ronda Santos
came out and sat down and had a real
conversation where they addressed the
Deep fakes where they talked about uh
this ad his his polling would Skyrocket
double digits overnight overnight his
predicted would jump way up but he's
avoiding it hoping to make it all go
away like it's 1993 and we're using old
school PR tactics of if you say nothing
it goes away yeah take a look at Bud
Light dude people aren't forgetting
these things they're taking them
seriously and you know president Trump
has demonstrated that you can put people
in positions of great power
and then fire them and talk them
endlessly right let's let's jump to this
next story
um about Bud Light because this is big
for the post millennial bottling plants
shut down after Bud Light sales tank
amid Dylan Mulvaney partnership so the
news is
645 jobs lost employees out of work
after the our dog group shut down two
plants according to WRAL it was because
there was a decrease in demand falling
Bud Light sales and thus they had no
reason to make bottles anymore because
Bud Light doesn't need them ladies and
gentlemen
this is winning the culture war and this
is substantive but there was always
going to be Collateral Damage I feel bad
for the people who lost their jobs
because of this
but it's it's a fault of Bud Light well
there's also kind of it's really tragic
but there's sort of the other side of
it's not like America's drinking less
beer so maybe there are 450 or 500 more
jobs created another plant making the
bottles and whole you know but I know
the company's still wildly profitable
this is sort of the same trick that
Amazon does it's not a Budweiser plant
it's a subcontractor so it's a
subcontractor that has to eat all the
dirt the bad decisions that the the
contractor made yep
and uh inbev is uh what is it Belgian
Brazilian company anyway so I'm not no
offense I'm not too concerned or if they
go bankrupt I mean I'm not all gung-ho
on America right now but I'd like to see
these people go get a job with an
American Brewing Company like Yingling
or something
hopefully if Yingling sails Skyrocket
Molson cores you know whatever then
there will be bottling demand but it's
interesting the point you bring up
people are still buying beer so they're
still they still need to bottle beer so
what's happening these other these other
uh bottling plants are doubling their
workload and these people are getting
laid off not really a great situation
but I I just want to say like
this is actually a sign of permanent
economic damage to a brand that decided
to get woke the damage to the brand
probably can't be overstated can't be
undone either no you could also get a
job with ultra right beer I'm not sure
if conservative dads Ultra right is
hiring at the moment but I'm sure they
will be soon I just drank about six of
those I imagine the police that lost the
500 jobs I imagine that is probably not
strategically located near another place
where these people can just transfer
over to another Brew uh another bottle
you know what's saddest about this is
that uh these people lost their jobs
some are probably not going to be able
to afford their mortgages it's going to
cost them their marriages cost them
their children cost them everything
whereas the CEO of Anheuser-Busch
see he's still employed he still happens
to the guy at the top he's double
breaking it in they're they're
subsidizing a lot of these uh these
companies that would be Carlos Brito is
his name he's Brazilian guy they did can
the CEO of the woman that uh was oh no
yeah but do you think they're denying it
but it's been reported that her the the
woman uh and the the guy have been like
two people were removed well you know
they got a fat severance package they're
not out on the street they're not like
these blue-collar people in North
Carolina no no official officially
here's what I think happened officially
they're not fired they're on leave
but uh literally according to sources in
the company they are considered
completely separate from the company the
reason they're not firing them is
because Anheuser-Busch fears a lawsuit
they they fear that they'll get sued
some labor dispute so by putting them on
an indefinite leave and saying nothing
they can get rid of them they're fired
effectively but officially they're not
fired but they're also going to become
folk Heroes on the left they're going to
get a well-paid job with the uh any
number of left-wing groups that are
supportive of what they did so they're
gonna land very well I don't have any
doubt maybe but the left is clearly
losing
I mean remarkably I mean this is
catastrophic I think virtue's signaling
loses and it especially loses in
business man when you're all you care
about is making a profit nobody cares
what you think yeah but who's bearing
the I get it and I guess companies are
now a lot more cautious about doing
anything woke right but look at what
happened here and look who actually paid
the price these blue collar workers who
probably vote
the way we'd like them to vote who are
good loyal Americans they're the ones
out of their job the people who are
responsible for the decision they're
getting golden parachutes they're going
to get go work for glad one of the left
wing homosexual groups or something
they're going to do great they should
have quit when this happened so
when the controversy started and you saw
sales declining and the stock was
tanking you've had three months to find
a different job you mean the bottling
Factory people
I don't know if it's as easy for them as
we might I didn't say it was easy it was
easy but I get it you can see the storm
coming and I'm sorry I'm not happy these
people are losing their jobs however I
am not going to stand in support of
people who are propping up what Bud
Light was doing I don't think they even
had any awareness of it they're just
they're just shift workers who probably
didn't barely finish high school if
anything like that I don't think they
had these are pure civil like there are
people who know better
I have less sympathy for them the idea
that you okay look what Bud Light was
doing with Dylan Mulvaney I believe is
the banality of evil the algorithm is
propping up this borat-like character
that is insulting to most people and you
working at these factories and
supporting Bud Light are affect are are
one of the individuals holding up that
machine engaging in the banality of evil
I don't blame people for not knowing
because people try to do good and you
know we try to inform them but I'm not
going to shed a tear if there is an evil
organization doing evil things you are
helping them and then like if if you're
the henchman for a super villain and you
get fired because the villain's been
arrested I'm not gonna be like oh that's
really said he's out of job I'll be like
good less henchmen for the villain I
just don't think you can hold somebody
with like a 90 IQ who's doing everything
they can within the law to raise their
family and has doesn't have the
capability of seeing what you and I can
see because we're in this world I just
they're just innocent civilians that got
caught up in this I I disagree they are
components of a machine that is engaging
in cultural destruction Decay and the
banality of evil the only reason I don't
blame them as individuals for marching
in lockstep with an evil machine but if
we're going to stop the cultural
degradation they have to lose their jobs
but the people who made the decisions
are not punished at all and they're just
going to go on to the next company and
do it again
the the people at the bottom are holding
this machine up I do not believe the
goal is to intentionally hurt the
regular workers but even if you want to
punish them there's no amount of
punishment that's going to make them
understand what they need to understand
to fix this then we're in agreement the
only thing you can do is dismantle the
machine and that means the people at the
bottom are going to lose their jobs
first there's nothing else you can do
you're not you're never gonna get even
if they fire the CEO you're talking
about cutting off the head of a Hydra
two more grow back in its place these
individual workers the bottling plants
that are producing Bud Light and selling
it are generating the profits for an
evil machine you could seize the company
with the government and then
that's one tactics I mean they're just
so easily replaced if they decide oh
we're all going to quit let's move the
plant to Mexico or something like that
is the next thing it's the people that's
not what happened the demand dropped so
much the plants don't exist anymore
which is good the demand shifted to
another brand somewhere else which may
or may not be in the United States I
guess we're probably not going to agree
on this I think the enemies the snakes
at the top and you just you it's like
you can't hold these people
they're it's not even if you want to
hold them accountable you just can't
because they're not capable of being
held accountable like look look you are
correct the problem is the leadership of
Anheuser-Busch Michael Duke have a
standing army in front of them blocking
you from putting in from stopping the
evil practices well I think we've we
succeeded in a way because look these
guys are gonna not make as much money as
they would have otherwise two people who
are pretty high profile kind of lost
their jobs and gonna have a tough time
of it so they and we can see the effect
is because all these companies are so
eager to celebrate pride month you know
regardless what you think of it they
kind of toned it down a little and some
other companies sort of backed up stuff
Target yeah they backed up so to me the
the profits for the people at the top
getting cut is really all they care
about so if you can hit that that's kind
of how you adjust the culture but that
is the collateral damage that will
trickle down and hit the bottom work
well there's a reason it's called
collateral damage right so my point is I
want these people to find jobs I don't
blame them for the actions of the
organization but it is a good thing
there that these jobs were lost
Spotlight shrinking is good that means
people lose their jobs I don't know if
it's corporatism or capitalism that
protects the CEO and the owners of the
company when they're they can just
liquidate their work staff and they
don't have to pay any price for
destroying their company's profits you
would say like that's why communism some
people might want it because the
government can go take the company away
and say you misused it you're gone
that's that's not even communism I mean
there can be Consumer Protections in a
capitalist system we don't strip the CEO
of his job of his duty I mean
stockholders through due process if a
crime is committed well if it's a crime
but since it's not a crime in the
capitalist system we've been letting
CEOs get away with it for years right
how do you want to making is communism
is not the answer no I know that's why
we have a capitalist system and it's
better than communism but how do you
protect the workers all right so you
pass laws protecting workers so like you
can have a capitalist system that says
specifically if you intentionally
destroy the company to hurt workers
there can be some kind of intervention
that it's not absolute there's not
either capitalism or com communism is
not the right word for because it's
political it's not either capitalism or
socialism there's a varying degree
controlled yeah whatever so having
having some protection I think that some
protections are are a good thing but but
ultimately my point here is
what did anyone think was going to
happen you stop buying Bud Light there
is less money going to Bud Light they
will fire many people
we are not mad at the people who got
fired it is a good thing Bud Light is
shrinking that's it yeah and so your
question is how do you solve this in the
Kabbalah system you know the original
Union organizer who is not a communist
he's an immigrant named Samuel Gompers
had the solution and that was for
workers to form a union and use their
bargaining power to actually acquire the
company since the workers that own the
company so they pull their funds they
buy more and more stock board positions
to eventually a situation where you know
the founder dies and passes on and then
they sell the company the workers so
when you have a worker-owned company it
provides a lot of protection
unfortunately the union movement in this
country went into the direction of
politics and I aiding politics and
wanting not to take over management but
to fight with management for purposes of
demagoguing and delivering votes to a
political party so that's kind of where
we lost our way but there is a solution
it is fully compatible with capitalism
but also it's a globalist company like
in uh a b inbev is a Belgian is it
Belgian company it's Brazilian and but
uh
where it is um but so how do our
American Union laws function with a
multinational corporation a a union
there's they're still publicly traded
you give that Union that had the play
the people working in North Carolina or
workers Co-op a few board seats
you'd see a different outcome
they can earn those board seats
so uh and I got some news in this
related area and I I seek advice from uh
our loyal viewers so as many of you know
we're working on a coffee shop and um
there are some issues related to laws
which are causing it to get delayed
massively
it's an old building and so in order to
get it up to code and everything it's a
ridiculous amount of work and it's a
historical building so then there's like
you got to have a lot of paperwork so
we're looking at we're looking at
Charlestown West Virginia not too far
away from Harpers Ferry and there's a
building for sale it is very big it's
right in this in in downtown and we went
and checked it out very excited and uh
there was a restaurant there very
recently they sold and they moved and I
said how cool would it be to set up one
our first or second location depending
on which gets done first of cast brew
coffee here in downtown Charlestown
we went and met with the uh two agents
our agent and their agent checked out
the whole building it is massive so big
in fact we might even be able to put a
skate shop in the back with a separate
entrance very excited for this there's a
stage that's already there very cool
afterwards we went across the street to
get breakfast and while I was getting
breakfast at a little diner called
Grandma's Diner there was a newspaper
called the spirit of Jefferson in it I
learned that Charlestown passed a pride
month resolution the city council of
Charlestown West Virginia voted to
declare June pride month in support of
all they blah blah blah and long-winded
garbage
and so I said man
what do you do
you invest in a town that is moving in
that direction
or
do we make it a point to not invest in
places like this
there's a couple arguments the first is
if we do invest in this town we gain
influence in this town we bring people
to this town employees fans and we start
changing the culture for the better
what if that doesn't work and the town
keeps moving in this negative Direction
and they end up doing things that are
shocking and offensive to our customers
to our friends and fans and we lose that
fight and waste all of our money
the argument against it
is Maybe
maybe the city needs to see economic
Fallout from making decisions like this
so that the people of the town get angry
so I I wonder I kind of lean towards the
best thing to do is actually invest in
the town and buy the business and then
put up flags and signs saying like no to
all of this invite people down and start
shaping the culture with our resources
in force
there is the potential of going to the
city and saying so long as you have this
resolution in effect we will not spend a
dime here I feel like that one doesn't
necessarily work as much it may sound
good but it's like if your money was
never available to the city in the first
place they don't care what you think if
your money becomes available and you say
but I want to see this thing no longer
enforce you actually make a difference
so I'm curious what the people for those
of you that are listening what do you
think is the best thing to do should we
open a shop in Charlestown West Virginia
even though just now in June only a
couple weeks ago five to three the city
voted in support of pride month
which is just so insane as a whole month
dedicated to whatever it is they're
doing
or should we just tell them go to the
agents and tell and say hey
let let the people in the city know when
you when you tell them you can't sell
the building it's because we don't want
to invest in a town like this you know
it's funny you bring this up because I I
your point of view on this is sort of a
um sort of the moral argument of having
the conversation with the c what do you
want to do what consequence you want to
face and I think that the reality is
there's no entity to have that
discussion with and there's no entity
that would react to say losing a
business or entry and actually do these
campaigns all over the country
constantly for other things like uh
somebody wants to build a new super
center for a a big uh like a big box
store right and the community doesn't
want so I get in and you know either
help them defeat or help them bring it
in or something like that it sounds like
all you really need to do is flip two
city council seats you get a stealth
campaign you find two good candidates
you fund them and you take it over and
you say no more pride month and you know
that's the exact same way the George
Soros took over all these prosecutors
get a stealth campaign get a smart
political consultant recruit the
candidates and you flip it and then you
have but the idea of all I didn't mean
I'm just telling you that's that's how
you maybe something you could do I don't
know
I'm not I'm not that kind of guy I'm not
gonna but it's not even like a stealth
underhanded tactic it's the way of the
world you find people that you believe
in and you elevate them to positions of
power to help lead you and your legal
system who do you think got those five
people that voted for pride month on the
city council people who disagree with
you the issue I yes more so I think the
issue is
the people even though the majority of
people oppose all of that stuff they do
not do anything they don't vote they
don't get up they don't speak out they
complain in private and it's really
really frustrating the idea that West
Virginia the second most Trump
supporting state in in the country would
allow woke prosecutors and they do in
Martinsburg they had a drag show in
public with children and brought them on
stage which is illegal in West Virginia
unquestionably illegal
and no one's doing anything about it and
they all say it's not my problem I don't
I have no Authority sorry I can't do it
the people it's it's surprising a rural
County in West Virginia
voted for woke District woke prosecutors
it sounds like there's a void of
organization in this world and
especially in this country and
particularly in West Virginia but
probably a lot of states that we need to
develop some sort of organization like
we need to if it's just like sorry
little kids on stage with people waving
their junk around out of their face
whatever like someone needs to go in
there and not lay down the law but
create order the average person is still
like learning about this stuff like most
people don't really have a a deep
knowledge about things like queer Theory
and then you've got but
well good well you then you've got like
the whole like half of the the country
feeding a narrative that this isn't
about trying to abuse kids you've got
the whole media establishment trying to
convince people that this isn't about
trying to indoctrinate kids into a
political mindset but you don't need to
understand anything about queer Theory
to be like hey that child on stage
taking his clothes off for money is a
very bad thing
well look the reason this is Advanced as
far as it has is because the left is
well funded and well organized flipping
these back the other way Martinsville
Martinsville Martinsburg Martinsburg
even Charleston West Virginia it wasn't
like Charlestown Charles Charlestown
yeah it's not it wasn't an eight to one
vote it was a five to three that means
look if we can just get the right people
informed and turn out to vote and it's
not that hard it just takes organization
a little bit of funding and it it's not
that hard well I was like you know I was
talking to the agent
saying like I'm not sure it's it's a
good idea to invest in a town that wants
to go the direction of Bud Light clearly
we are seeing a major backlash to what
Bud Light Target Starbucks and those
other companies have done to the tune of
tens of billions of dollars
and I'm supposed to invest my money and
start my business in town that's going
that same direction well here's the
problem though eventually you're going
to run out of places to escape from so
you have to pick a place to make your
stand and fight and you know this is a
place where I think
uh an end if somebody as smart as you
could come in and apply the right
pressure and become part of that
community
I think you could flip it and you you
may just be the person that could do the
degree of pressure I would exert is
talking about it on this show having
events at our coffee shop with comedians
putting up Flags in the window or
something that may be all it takes to
find the additional Community organizers
to go out and go hit doors and explain
it because most the voters who even
voted for the five people they probably
didn't even know that they voted that
way yeah exposing them second year
they've done this though it's within
reach really Within Reach yeah five to
three isn't eight to zero you know it's
not San Francisco yeah exactly fair
enough you know
it is disheartening to know that all
right I'm going to invest you know I'm
gonna you know invest in this community
and there's people in this community
that you know obviously are not active
or not aware of political uh things that
that you know affect us or that we care
about
um but again five to three is not eight
to zero so
I think that most of the the problem is
that conservatives are still mostly
unaware you know people that would have
a problem with this kind of stuff are
still mostly unaware
um that there are things like this going
on and and if you can just wake them you
know make them aware of it not it's not
even about waking them up it's just like
make them aware because
I've said before all the people that I
talk to that are left-leaning that are
you know your your default Democrats
when it comes to you know the lgbtq Ia
plus stuff the the trans issues and
stuff like that even the most
Progressive of progressives
say things like look they is a word that
has a meaning and it's useful we can't
just give it away to people it it
doesn't make sense in English so I mean
you see what uh what happened with Young
Turks with Anna kaspberry oh it's the
most enjoyable thing on Twitter oh my
gosh let's talk about it what happened
melting down so uh Anakin spreader The
Young Turks
criticized this uh non-profit for
calling women's privates bonus holes
and the reaction others because she had
a problem with being called the birthing
person and stuff but the latest one is
that she criticized Organization for for
referring to female parts as bonus holes
and what happened many leftist
commentators said she lied made it up
it's propaganda and not real yeah
shockingly insane and evil Hannah is
correct and I agree with her opinion
however I do find her to be duplicitous
in that we've agreed with her and jack
on so many things but they always
pretend to oppose us which is the
weirdest thing ever if she came in here
and sat down we would be like you're
completely right on all of your points
100 yep that's absolutely correct we
agree we talked about the same thing the
left comes out calls her right wing
calls him shills and says no one's
referring to his bonus walls so she
tweets the link to it saying here's the
organization calling women's Parts bonus
holes and they still claim she's lying
because there's two big components to
what the left commentary does lie about
what's actually happening because
they're ideologues who believe there's
no truth but power so they're justified
in their lives to gain power or they're
saying whatever they think is
in in opposition to the right so if
anything criticizes them they're on the
other side of it if anyone says this
book is bad then the book must be good
so when Anna comes out and says don't
call me a birthing person or having a
bonus hole they say you're lying that
never happened or your right wing
I noticed that same thing with uh elad's
footage of the marching the people that
were marching saying we're here we're
queer were from coming for your children
and in the comments they're like no no
that was just a moment at the March
where it was out of some there was
somebody inciting that thing someone got
in the way and started that chant they
weren't really saying that I'm like I
just watched the video five times like I
saw him say it a lot and there were a
lot of people I don't have any evidence
that someone was there inciting that and
it just seemed like lies like it was
like a cognitive dissonant thing like I
cannot accept this I must lie I must say
it didn't happen it's that cycle where
first they said oh it's not happening
it's just conspiracy theory and they say
oh it's sort of happening doesn't matter
and then they say oh it's a good thing
it's happening and that's what NBC
eventually wrote is that oh this is a
time-honored among the homosexuals
chanting that they're coming for your
children the normal thing they always do
that forever you should definitely get
Anna to come on
we've invited them oh on here on IRL
she'd be so fun not just culture
warships because because especially with
her her making apparently this is this
is something that's been going on for a
while she's been having disagreements uh
she came she was on sitchin Adams uh oh
yeah I want to go on their show yeah
they're listening they're looking to get
in touch with you um but she came out
and she's said that you know
um uh the the Kyle Rittenhouse case she
understands you know and she's on Kyle
ritten's writtenhouse aside which is in
opposition to Saints uh Shanks position
um she has an issue with being called a
birthing person or a uterus have or
whatever so there's a lot of things that
are going on on the left that she's
started to have an issue with and you
know kudos to her because every other
sane liberal person who realized what
was going on became disaffected liberal
yeah you know and and like I said kudos
to her because she's taking a a ton of
hell for it but you know the fact that
she actually can acknowledge that look
this is a lie and one of the things she
said on the on the on Adam such and
Adam's stream was that people were
gaslighting her and she's like I know
that you're lying to me and and I I
can't believe that you are still
continuing to Gaslight me because it's
not about her yeah it's about the
listeners
so what's up what a lot of these
channels do which uh uh you know I'll
leave there's many of them they just
fabricate everything they don't care
either because they're ideologically or
capitalistically driven it's really
fascinating they're like oh I'm on the
left and they buy massive mansions in
California
complete lies these people it's
remarkable that you look to these
prominent lefties who are talking about
all this you know I believe in helping
people in socialism and it's like oh who
have you who have you supported and
donated to no how dare you uh and then
you look to the quote-unquote right I
love this thing about the pro-choice
pro-life argument when the pro-choicers
lie all the time no that's unfair it's
not pro-choice it is the pro-abortion
side and the pro-life side because the
pro-choices are like in the middle and
like typically not starting with
conservatives on a lot of issues I mean
like actual approach choice where they
were like maybe within the first few
weeks but post viability no abortion the
reasonable Democrat position from a
while ago the pro-abortion crowd is just
lying about everything
I forgot exactly where I was going but
uh that's basically the the gist of it
you've got people who have
found themselves silenced and in the
middle as the left just says whatever it
is is the opposite of the right and then
lies about what's actually happening to
wind power are you taking a post-birth
abortion now people are claiming that
it's not actually happening but they're
I mean oh yeah all the media claiming
that no one ever brought it up when
Northam literally talked about even
resuscitating the baby and then bring it
to another room to decide what to do
there's also a phenomenon of liars
people that think it's good to lie and
they like they just do it I had a friend
growing up in granted we were like 13 or
14 at the time but we would play
Dungeons and Dragons and then he would
he'd roll and then he'd be like no I got
a five I'd be like dude you just rolled
a seven you'd be like no I got I had a
five dude I'm like you you it was a
seven like that's gaslighting but then
we play with a third guy would come over
and he'd be like no it was a five and
we'd both be like you're lying to us you
just won the seven he's like no I wrote
a five and how do you get through to
someone like that you don't we just said
we had to cut ways and like ostracize
the reason they can get through or get
away with it is because whoever Their
audience is isn't a very narrow Channel
they're not like checking out a lefty on
The Young Turks and I'll watch them pull
and sort of get both sides of story
their audiences are completely locked in
with people just like them and think
like them so you like still have people
this day you know yelling about January
Sixers killing five police officers that
day which yeah no but they believe it
because all their news sources repeat
that same lie and they're not exposed to
anybody outside of that or when they get
like they run to me I say oh that's not
true uh the only people that died were
protesters unarmed protesters like oh
you're lying that's not true
so we have two different I guess
realities so here's the issue I see with
like The Young Turks
I I've known known them for a very very
long time like longer than 10 years back
when he was a conservative you know not
when he was a conservative I remember I
remember and then and there's the post I
guess they were Jimmy dors said this I
could be wrong that they would post
photos of like upskirt shots or
something like that I don't know if
that's true or whatever it's been it's
been a while but was that what it was uh
that was uh Hassan Hassan started out
doing a lot of stuff like that Hassan
used to do that today he would be kind
of like the skirt not not exactly I'm
not going to put say he did upskirt
stuff but he was like early YouTube guy
posting like you know girls edgy stuff
some like dark stuff yeah but what I
think happened with them is they had a
large audience the cultural shift
started to happen in 2015 and they did
not want to go against their own
audience because
money was more important so they just
went along with whatever the current
thing was but eventually you break
eventually the left starts advocating
for insane things like post-birth
abortion unrestricted abortion calling
women birthing persons and have a bonus
hole havers and eventually you're just
like this is insane the problem I have
with the issue I take with The Young
Turks is that
they're still trying to pretend to be a
part of whatever the left is yeah
they'll say things like well we are on
the left because we believe in universal
healthcare it's like oh so so do I and
I've talked about that quite a bit on
the show they'll say yeah well you know
we're pro-choice I'm like that's funny
so am I we've had debates me and Sheamus
discuss this all the time they're lying
they're still lying even though Anna is
pushing back against lies on the left
they still lie and pretend that they're
not in agreement with us on a lot of
issues they still pretend to support
things that are completely untrue even
when Anna says something that's correct
as soon as someone on the right
compliments her or says here's what you
write about she'll come out and say yeah
well you're not but I'm still not on the
right and I disagree with you it's like
just stop this whole like desperate need
to be on the left is so annoying that's
why I'm like
you know I'll try and Define it what
does it mean to be culture War right
wing economically right-wing or socially
right-wing definitions matter but I'll
refer to this as the freedom faction or
the culture War right like I don't care
what you call it so long as we
understand what we're talking about
anyone that's like I am a fill in the
blank I'm a conservative I'm a liberal I
am a this even I am an American like you
are putting yourself in a box man and it
is a dark hole you cannot see out of
that thing but is it a bonus hole
probably I'd be willing to bet that on
most issues I'm to the left of Hassan
hands down I hope he hears this I'd be
willing to bet that if we actually had a
discussion on issues I would be to the
left of him on a whole bunch of
different issues I'm not but he would
lie no no he would lie this is my point
like I'll put it this way
if uh someone came to him and wanted to
work on some project with him that he
would Finance do you think he would
actually give them the majority of the
revenue generated from the project they
worked on I believe the answer would be
no I believe he'd be like no way no
absolutely not whereas here we often
discuss how if we launch a project the
people will the people work on that
project will retain the majority of the
revenue generated from it the company
like we seek to Foster talent and and
help people grow
I've I've publicly donated to several
people in several causes I I like I'm
not trying to start beef with him or
anything like that I'm just saying I
think these people are just
entertainment personalities who will
claim to support a thing like Ethan
Klein or whatever they'll they'll
feigned being on a political side for
entertainment value but I guarantee you
if it ever came down to seizing the
wealth of Hassan he would fight
you tooth and nail he would take up arms
against a Communist Revolution in two
seconds to stop his his to stop the
seizure of his multi-million dollar
mansion in California I don't know about
that he's Bourgeois Bourgeois I guess
and I agree with you I don't like
talking about I don't want to cause
drama is a little Anna's awesome she's
brilliant remember that guy in
California who was cheering on the
rioting and post the photo of the
burning building and then as soon as
they started marching towards Beverly
Hills he was like no don't come here
that's what I'm talking about so I'm not
saying I know for sure maybe I'm wrong
about a son I don't watch a ton of his
stuff but the fact that even when I've
tried like when I've agreed with him and
Anna they still act like I'm wrong it's
the weirdest thing is that the way you
agreed no you were too it was too
tonally angry when I made a literal
video where I was like Hassan's totally
right and everyone's wrong to criticize
him here's why he's right he made a
video laughing at me oh where you guys
were you like video response
picture-in-picture video responses but
like he made a video and then I
responded to it saying he was correct in
his assessment here's why and then he
made a video saying that I was wrong
about a bunch of things and then
laughing at some of the points I'm like
I don't understand like I'm agreeing
with you it is fake money too the drama
is good for clicks and Views and AD
Revenue but it's we got to get to a
point where we get past that just well
Shuffle it off like ballast and get up
into orbit this is why I think the
culture War show check it out at
youtube.com timcast Friday mornings 10
a.m is important because it's really
hard for these people to pull this stuff
off when they're live next to other
people which is why so many left refused
to come on shows live they know in their
Bubble World like you were mentioning
where people Their audience isn't
exposed to anything else they can say
whatever they want but when they're
sitting here everyone else can see them
for who they really are
let's jump to this next story from
deadline because we've got good news and
I'm really excited uh to to cover the
story Jim caviezel's anti-child
trafficking Thriller sound of Freedom
not just 10 million dollar pre-sales
before July 4th and then we have this
sound of freedom and Indiana Jones duke
it out on July 4th for the number one
spot check this out
Indiana Jones had
11.698 million
over sound of freedoms 11.5 million
sound of sound of Freedom was only a
couple hundred thousand dollars away
from being the number one film on the
4th of July
there's a lot to consider here
Indiana Jones made 83.7 million over the
weekend so most people who wanted to see
the new Indiana Jones saw it over the
weekend
people aren't going to watch it twice on
the 4th of July but still the fact that
an indie film is rivaling a major
release only a few days later is
tremendous
y'all should go see this movie for two
big for two reasons it's really good
I think half the theater was crying for
the first 45 minutes there's some really
great story writing in there really
awesome stuff I'm not going to spoil the
second reason is to help Foster that
parallel economy supporting indie films
that are outside of Hollywood so that
industry can compete and flourish and we
can push back against this garbage is
extremely important I got some questions
about sound of Freedom you saw it
absolutely is using a documentary no
okay does it Thriller talk about oh does
it talk about the Cobalt mines in Africa
no okay so it is specifically the story
of Timothy Ballard who was a uh U.S law
enforcement Homeland Security and how he
quit his job to go and rescue kids who
are being trafficked and it is brutal
and GM plays Jim Caviezel plays Ballard
you know you're like like
man everybody in the theater was crying
like non-stop throughout the for the
first 45 minutes and then again like 10
minutes later there's Parts where you
get happy because the heroes are winning
you stop crying and then it goes back to
what's going on in this world and you
just like fighting back tears you know
what a lot of you know say what you will
about him he's a guy with obviously some
flaws but Mel Gibson this is his film
this is his isn't it I don't know he's
one of my favorite actors of all time I
love him Mel come over yeah I know he's
working on a documentary about uh you I
think it's about Ukraine and trafficking
and stuff like this but I don't I don't
know I'm kind of worried about wanting
to go to going to see this and then
walking out of the theater wanting to go
like hunt down pedophiles or something
being like so butt charged for that but
that's the point of the film and by hunt
down the correct answer is support
legitimate organizations that team up
with international law enforcement to
bring these people down this is what
Ballard's organization does it's it's
you want to stop these pedos and these
traffickers
and you want you want to get involved in
that you watch this movie and afterwards
that's that's exactly what I was
thinking I was like how are we not
putting more money into stopping what's
going on because these it is it is it is
nightmarish this it looks like Mel
Gibson is not attached to this film as
far as I can tell uh eduard Eduardo Vera
is the producer and we have Alejandro
Monte Verde is the director written by
Rod Barr and Alejandro himself
Monteverde so I don't think Mel is
attached to this like what ages do you
for the audience is wondering what uh
which ages do you think would be
appropriate to see this oh 18 and up
really I mean what's the what's the
rating on the movie actually According
to Jim cavie's old Mel Gibson did weep
when he saw the movie oh bro like
everyone in theaters that's what I was
talking about I everyone everyone in the
theater was crying I I was I I will say
this I was on the verge of tears
and you know
I just fought him back fought him back
but everyone around me is crying
uh what was the rating I'm looking it up
I don't see what what the movie was
rated because uh
nothing it doesn't show anything
explicit
but it's heavily implied like you know
what's happening there's a scene where
there's a little girl in the bed and a
creepy guy walks in and then it shows
out the window and he closes the blinds
like you get it a kid would understand
what's going on but adult would I don't
think you want to bring kids to this
movie you know this and it's such a
universally repulsive thing that this
movie attacks and go after like even in
prison you know you hear stories the
people that get it worse that every the
worst criminals in the world will turn
on is the people that get sent to prison
for abusing children so it's just it's
like a universal thing at least in our
culture is that this is the lowest of
the lowest of the low end
I think the point of this film is it's
not really being taken as seriously as
it should how do you read it it's PG-13
wow how do you redeem the people like
that pedophiles how do you redeem
pedophile how do you make them no longer
pedophiles
it's the hardest thing well obviously
I'm not talking about like well no no
they they they they I I'm I'm fairly
certain that uh they found recidive
recidivism among child abusers is like
that's the worst part and then it's the
people that have been abused as kids
grow up and then they think either it's
okay because it happened to them or
there's some sort of weird so like
breaking that cycle is what Humanity
needs to do without because we can't
just kill ourselves off and stop it that
way that's not effective you arrest them
well that's one way you can you can slow
it down I gotta tell you I want to say
this
when I was watching this movie
I started having a whole bunch of
thoughts about the moral philosophy of
Crime and Punishment and the appropriate
Solutions and how you deal with these
people because there's a lot of people
that have advocated for the death
penalty for uh traffickers especially
and for pedophiles you watch this movie
and you'll go
I completely understand the moral
position the issue is and I'm watching
this movie
that this I I don't want to spoil
anything but let me just tell you
there's no mustache twirling villain
there's not a guy who's like we're
taking kids it's like the scary thing is
the banality of it the guy who grabs a
little girl and throws her in an attack
in in a in a a cargo box and then gets
handed an envelope of cash and walks
away like nothing happened the
Simplicity the horror of it I thought to
myself what is the punishment for
destroying Humanity in this way
and I understand why people say that
through due process quite literally like
well I'm not going to play any stupid
games and and talk bravado like you
arrest them and then then they get
sentenced to death my fear is always the
death penalty is that innocent people
will get caught up in it and if one
percent of the people who are charged
are innocent put to death we have a very
very very serious problem I side with
the founding fathers blackstone's
formulation but when you see this film
it really makes it difficult and I
thought to myself I don't think the
founding fathers understood the massive
scale of child sex trafficking and
slavery that would be happening when
they were alike we should be very very
concerned or maybe the reality is they
truly understood the depravity of evil
in this world and understood the
importance of innocent until proven
guilty and you know due process rights
but I gotta tell you
I don't know what the solution is but
when you see these crimes being
perpetrated
I I oh man
I just got to tell you I understand why
people advocate for amending the laws to
have the death penalty for child
exploitation you know one one place to
start would be to get our government to
stop perpetuating this because you know
that in Afghanistan this is kind of a
big part of that culture and the United
States went to war against a regime that
was very bad but did Outlaw this and we
Allied ourselves with one that
perpetuated and we had our own soldiers
suffering PTSD because their allies
would go in the Next Room and molest a
child and they were ordered not to do
anything about it and then they had to
come back with that knowing that they
were protecting those people and
perpetuating that government and they
still have to live that and God knows
what the children over there have to go
through there is a scene man I really
don't want to spoil this movie but let
me just tell you
so you can understand without spoiling
the film
this is about an undercover operation oh
man what do you think a person in an
under I I shouldn't I shouldn't frame it
like this he doesn't the the main
character never does anything untoward
but when you're in law enforcement
like in the beginning of the movie he's
doing his job he has to review evidence
and it's just like him crying the whole
time and I'm just like
there's there's a there's a scene in the
trailer so it's not a spoiler where a
guy's like I cannot do this job and he
like walks off it's like yeah dude who
could I'm surprised there's anybody who
could who could stand that but if nobody
does that job these evil people get away
with it and may turn other people into
evil people that's the worst part about
it is it affects children when they're
young and then it can twist them early
and and dude the writing is so good
I I like I want to spoil the movie so
bad so I want to tell you just how good
it was but I can't I gotta wait I gotta
wait I had a fantasy about interviewing
Charles Manson before he died because I
thought if we can somehow get through to
the worst of the worst and let them tell
their story and you see why they became
that way maybe that's like a step
towards antidote you don't think someone
like Manson actually has like
uh is sick because I I think that there
are some people that are that have
mental illness that are really really
sick and they need they need to be taken
out of regular Society not be not
because I want to want them to or
because I think that that they deserve
to be punished or whatever but because
they're actually sick there are
medications that do help there are
people that if they don't take their
medication they do behave in ways that
are unacceptable they harm themselves
they'll harm other people so I don't
know I don't know that I agree with like
with with the idea that you can figure
out what's wrong and just love them back
to health I think it's there's a lot of
mental illness that is really really
really sick people that really need the
medications and he's right and he's he's
right for an even bigger reason
you and him you know being on the edge
of Tears watching that movie The reason
you're on the edge of Tears the reason
it makes you upset and angry is because
you have something that is called
empathy and empathy requires your
ability to map somebody else's mind to
sort of simulate what they are feeling
what they're experiencing some people do
not have the capability to do that it
usually tracks with like being lower
intelligence that's why you have so many
criminals they're also not very
intelligent the reason is that they
don't have the ability to think about
how another person would feel rece on
the receiving end of their behavior they
don't know how to do unto others as you
let to do under yourself they have no
idea how to imagine how anybody else
would feel they'll punch you in the face
without thinking about it because it
never what prevents us in many ways from
doing evil things gosh if somebody did
that to me I would be horrified that
would be and you empathize so these
people don't have the ability to do that
and it's not something you can really
create you know I think there's a simple
way to to view a movie like this
in order for humans to survive I'll put
it in evolution terms we protect
children why is that a mama Grizzly is
going to Maul you if you get too close
to her babies because of the love for
her babies why does that love exist well
if we're going to simplify it in science
it's because if there is a species that
does not care for its babies it is less
likely to procreate and survive and
eventually will not exist so there's a
couple different evolutionary strategies
bees just have tons of babies just tons
and tons and tons like bugs that's what
they do rabbits run really fast have
lots of babies they do care about their
young mammals tend to cats too animals
too
when humans see children being exploited
abused in these horrifying ways the
overwhelming majority of humans have a
natural anger and sadness response
because we want to protect children we
have to want it as ingrained within us
dude
you go see this movie The reason why I
say I gave it a 10 out of 10. very few
movies matter
you go and watch a popcorn flick you go
and watch Spider-Man you're like that's
fun you go and watch any one of these
you know releases that have come out as
of recent and it's just like Fast and
Furious I don't care about Fast and the
Furious I mean it's funny we joke about
it silly you know Vin Diesel's driving a
car and the car is going outer space
with ludicrous or whatever and we're and
it's and it's and it's meaningless
when you watch The Sound of freedom
you're being told a story about
something tremendous and meaningful that
moves you in the real world these
stories you hear about exploitation
based on a true story that obviously
there's writing involved based on a true
story but they have real surveillance in
this movie like actual surveillance
videos not a part of the story but they
show it in like like a certain until you
understand
like these things actually matter so
you're watching a film
that is fiction based on a true story
overwhelmingly true but there's like
obviously a lot of fiction in it and the
feelings you're getting are real
emotions whereas like when I'm rooting
for Vin Diesel to defeat the bad guy
like it's not a real fear I'm not a
really I don't really care if he wins or
not once the movie's over I'm gonna
leave anyway I'm gonna leave and throw
my popcorn in the garbage and be like
and I'm gonna forget what happened to
Vin Diesel a day later this movie you
feel something about the real world that
moves you and I'm like that's why I
think this movie is so good Not only was
it really well produced great music
great pacing uh cinematography on par
with any other Hollywood flip which is
impressive for an indie film it's like a
story that makes you feel something real
that actually matters that's impressive
sounds like it's called the sound of
freedom because freedom
is not pleasant it means you're aware of
what's going on the name has is related
to the film you'll understand if you
watch them you know there's a precedence
for saying this film which you hope it
to be a couple of times I can think of
one example was a novel called Uncle
Tom's Cabin and that led to the freedom
of the slaves and you know whether you
agree with this or not uh Brokeback
Mountain move the needle on support for
call it gay marriage and in the same way
perhaps this film will motivate us to
take this problem much more seriously
and do something about it Jim Caviezel
says that he says that hopefully this
film can be akin to Uncle's Uncle Tom's
Cabin and inspire people to do something
about the slavery and traffic that is
currently happening around the world
today there are more slaves in the world
today than ever before even when slavery
was legal 100 yep well it is legal in
Africa in the Congo and I don't see
these tech companies doing much to try
to stop that so if you want to protect
the slaves you can do it in real time
right just now also the Border we need
to protect the kids coming across the
border so I'll say this like when I
heard about this movie and people were
saying like she goes you should go see
it in no way did I think anything about
it was a conservative movie or what was
a faith-based movie I didn't hear
anything about that I went and saw it
and it was good and it's like it's weird
in the Press
admittedly a couple of outlets have
praised the film even saying don't call
it a conservative movie it's just a
movie and it's really good and that's it
there's a couple references to God in a
very vague and nebulous way that doesn't
even necessarily invoke religious
connotations it's uh it's in the trailer
so I'm not you know spoiling anything
it's actually the hashtag God's children
are not for sale that's why they thought
it was a conservative movie probably
because of that one but that's not even
like a religion like an overtly
religious thing it's like Destiny
there's there's a line about you know
when when when God gives you the calling
and it's like
yo you don't have to be Christian or
religious to to understand concepts of
fate and destiny you know what I mean
just because someone says the word like
regular like secular people can
understand what it means to have fate
yeah so like anyway I'll say this you're
not going to get any religious stuff out
of this film you know if you are
religious you'll love it anyway and if
you're not there's no deep preaching or
anything in it it's just a good it's
like uh
I don't know it's like any other law
enforcement here's the crazy thing
that's something going to be like I've
seen these movies about like fighting
the cartels before but like the issue in
the story is not something you actually
care about like you watch a movie where
it's like it's based on a true story
stopping this drug cartel I'm like I
don't care about a drug cartel like I I
yeah awesome movie I care that we stop
drug trafficking I care that we stop
these bad guys but like the issue of
pulling over a truck with a bunch of
cocaine in it does not move me watching
a dude save a child and seeing the
reaction these these actors these kids
were really really phenomenal seeing
that it's like someone reaches into your
soul and starts squeezing and you can
feel it and it's it's I guess I say you
see that movie but let's go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and head over to timcast.com
become a member of the members only show
be coming up at about 10 p.m and we've
got much much more to talk about because
there was a tragic incident that
occurred uh this these past couple of
days and um we're gonna save this one
because it could be spicy for the
members only show
all right I'm not your buddy guy says I
am fully convinced leftism is civil
civilizational cancer that metastasizes
until the host ceases to exist it value
its values of the seven deadly sins
we're not the first and won't be the
last to face this threat
I would say what we describe as left as
in today more so it's like wokism and um
I guess I guess what I'm trying to say
is if we're talking about left economic
philosophy a lot of it is really really
bad but it's not absolute it's like yin
yang within good there's evil isn't evil
there is good I think what we should
clarify is there is a cult that is an
amalgam of weird left leftist ideologies
and economics that in many ways
contradicts itself that is just burning
things down that's how I see it
yes that is important Mao used to to
denigrate the rightists he'd call them
those on the right he actually called
them rightists so this term leftist be
careful you don't become the enemy that
you seek to quell by becoming the
villain that's creating a lesser class
it's really about the twisting of the
Left Right Paradigm that is the problem
all right belly flop says I've been
really liberal for Trans adults but it's
gotten to the point where it's not
enough to be an ally as they say you
have to pick a gender flag
conversion agent Smith style me me
there's a a photo going viral of a woman
carrying an asexual pride flag and she
says asexual people deserve rights and
representation we've been discriminated
against and it's just like no you
haven't you literally not true there's
no persecution for people who are not
having sex in fact that was actually
required of people you know pre like a
long time ago in society they they were
they it was socially unacceptable to
have sex you had to not unless you were
married so like it's not a thing but
there's flags for everything though
everybody wants a flag this is very
strange
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I was
gonna wait until it dropped for home
watch but you've convinced me to see
sound of Freedom at a theater I hope all
had a great start to Maga month and a
fun Independence Day holiday USA
absolutely
yeah same room I'm not your buddy guy
says I thought you were changing logos
to US flag yes we have to do that I need
to uh go in and find the um
I have the eye of the the Twitter
profile picture oh yeah with the
American flag nice I think on Facebook
you can just do it because it saves them
yeah but on Twitter I have to actually
pull up the file distribute but it is
marked for a few days it is yeah I
wonder how that'll work considering
we're an organization though I don't
know if it will for your personal
account well because like we're all
verified through a business account it's
a different kind of verification
basically so like I could because of our
business account I can add someone's
name and they instantly get a blue check
so we should be able to just change
photos I think you will be fine
we will grab some more Super chats Mind
of a Madman says I actually got to load
some mortars for my family's fourth
celebration it was awesome and I still
have all my fingers
you guys see that video of the backfire
and the all the fireworks under the car
goes off and everyone's running I've
seen some x-rays oh yeah I have some
hand X-rays of like eight of them or ten
of them of what can go wrong that's wild
see in real life it's scary
Spencer Jones says happy birthday
America met Tim Ballard a few years ago
a real life superhero go see sound of
Freedom donate to our oh you are that's
Underground Railroad it's uh the
organization he founded to help save
kids
yeah really cool stuff man absolutely
all right let's grab some more Super
chats oh we got some criticism for you
Matt Kevin Brady says is Matt going to
suggest we buckle up again before
nothing happens
yeah great I mean look ahead has been
doing a lot of work just because the
media doesn't cover it doesn't mean it
doesn't happen we've obtained multiple
convictions for voter frauds we've
gotten voters who are eligibility
removed from about uh voter lists all
over the country we've introduced and
gotten legislation passed all over the
country that's helping secure the
election check out look ahead
america.org we're putting up new wins
every day right on
Let's uh let's see what we got with some
super chats
J.R Williams in the regular chat with a
blue Bean he says Tim has never read one
of my super chats or super or SS's I
don't know what that SS stands for well
I read that one sir I read that one sir
I saw it SS Super sticker super that's
what I thought but like you can't read
that you're like when you're like do I
just feel like you know here is a
picture of a purple puffball jumping up
and down and dancing I wonder if we
could show it on the screen
no I don't know how yeah we don't know
how we can't do that
what do we got with the old super chats
Michael TB says you can't take cocaine
or any drugs into the White House as a
visitor trust me on this I know for sure
there are dogs in the visitor entrance
yeah no for real like I had to go
through like three layers of security
when I when I went there this is insane
yeah you need to make a past background
check before you go and everything
that's yeah it's pretty strenuous
Christina H says hi guys any chance we
will see Tim Ballard on the show soon I
don't know Perhaps Perhaps we'll see
um we'll see stay tuned
arashi Yoshida says didn't Obama visit
the White House in the past week or so
that proves it party time that proves it
I saw a video of Hunter Biden like he
looked like he was tweaking out I think
it was the Fourth of July celebration
yeah you can see that video is only a
couple seconds oh yeah people are
pointing it was like tweaking yeah
raybert G stanbert JR says Tim I'd just
like to remind you of that working
Theory you had that Hunter is actually
the hero of the story trying to take his
father down by destroying his reputation
at every turn
yep Hunter is actually a very sound mind
and he's like my father is evil I will
be the man who brings him down and then
it's like his business partner Devon
Archer whatever his name is is like
don't do it you'll ruin your name and
say yes but I'll save this country I'll
do it he's undercover he's like don't
take the crack you'll get addicted to it
I have to I need to be the play of the
role it's the only way to save this
country from my father
laughs
I actually think Biden Joe Biden
probably I think he probably abused his
kids
or neglected him I think he abused them
I mean you look at all the videos of Joe
sniffing kids and stuff like that and
the fact that Hunter Biden allegedly
called his dad what do you call him pedo
Pete or something like that well there
was a journal entry right right oh I
know right Ashley from Ashley
inappropriate stuff we'll just put into
that
we will grab some more Super chats our
piece has Ian I remember Roger the
boring dispatcher oh my gosh what is
that a friend of mine uh YouTuber 2006
and 70 was the actual truck dispatcher
and we used to make videos and kind of
hated each other at first and then we
became friends then I wrote a song about
him called Roger which is out there it's
on Amazon and all sorts of platforms all
right he says Tim hire me just because
we got a a picture that just came in
from Vernon hooray I saw this so I'm
going to read it now listening from
behind your guest characterizing bottle
workers as low intelligent innocent
victims is elitist bigotry of low
expectations these people don't need you
to hold their hands
I guess this guy's gonna take some of
that money he threw at you and use a
little bit more of it to give them jobs
and help them pay their mortgages and
keep their kids in school Etc
perhaps yeah I feel bad they lost their
jobs but it's like
if there's a dude building you know a
tower of evil I'm not going to be like
oh what a good guys I'm so it's so
unfortunate that he has no job now that
we've stopped the evil from building
their Tower you know what I mean my
concern is like as citizens of the
United States and we've with our tax
money have supported the oversea wars
the CIA coups and things like that like
are we not part of this evil machine and
like what if we lose our jobs what does
that mean we're all taxpayers at the
stable right are we not part of the evil
just as much as these workers in North
Carolina
because by being taxpayers there's like
a big difference between being a
taxpayer and like working for Bud Light
it's different but I I have a similar
feeling when I think about what I'm
supporting sometimes and like it would
it be the righteous thing if it would
that would be stripped away from me as
one of just the feeble workers of the
system
there's certainly a uh one thing I find
that very laughable is this idea that
people are are uh insulated from being a
part of any one of these machines like
yeah we pay taxes to the United States
which does a whole bunch of really awful
and evil things and the reality is if we
wanted to we could go and live in the
wilderness and people often say like
well you can't because everyone owns
something it's like dude trust me if you
wanted to you can go live in the
wilderness like nobody's gonna find you
like yeah there's there's a lot of No
Man's Land yeah you know you just
do you really want to do it most people
don't want to do it and they won't and
so they end up paying tax and being part
of a machine that does really really
awful things but um
I look at the United States and paying
taxes to it not as like
supporting abject evil I think the US
does bad things but I think the US is
overwhelmingly good we just have to
fight from within to fix it we have the
means to do so the people work at Bud
Light less so I mean I'm sure the bottle
plant workers who are subcontract could
complain but but like clearly doesn't
care and has no interest the the people
in this country can ballot Harvest
ballot Chase vote and actually get
Donald Trump elected again and then he
can start making those changes we have
seen tremendous changes made through the
United States so it's not absolute
there's absolutely problems in this
country that we are a part of and we
help support
but my point is
you know the somebody built Mordor you
know what I mean and I'm not going to be
upset that they've lost their jobs
because Mordor collapsed when the when
the ring fell into the fires of Mount
Doom all those workers on the Death Star
yeah seriously a meme on the internet
yeah about all the and and it is like to
be honest like that's different Luke
Skywalker like straight up killed
millions of people like like true like
kids fatherless seriously like how many
the Death Star was a planet-based it was
like a moon and Luke Skywalker blew it
up and there were people there and they
were like Jan like that's from Clark to
talk about like the janitors and like
the contractors the contractor the thing
is when you work on the Death Star you
know you're working on a death star or
some guy that you know you you knocked
your girl up out of high school uh you
decided to marry her do the right thing
try to start a family how you take a job
paying you know a little bit of above
minimum wage and you're just filling
bottles and the next thing you know some
CEO who's never going to feel any pain
at all from it
does something dumb and suddenly you're
out I have sympathy I just have
tremendous sympathy the people who work
on the Death Star don't think they're
working on them oh they you know if you
do you know you're working on the desk
so you're saying so you're saying that
when someone gets hired by a contractor
to build a building for the government
they know they're evil if there's a
difference between
putting on a uniform taking a weapon or
built going into a war zone and fixing a
tank in a war zone I think the Death
Star was a military base in outer space
that wasn't an enemy territory or
anything like that and a guy gets hired
to build like microwave panels with a a
Empire that is at War and you kind of
the United States well the point is the
clerk says that you have to accept for
some possibility for where you go to
work and my standard for people being a
technical contractor going out of the
Death Star that you know has a giant
weapon that's going to blow up planets
or did they it's a little maybe I think
they saw that I bet the Empire told them
it was called Happyville it was the
Death Star name is only the the rebels
that gave it that well yeah it's
propaganda but but the clerk they
probably called it like the US the USS
Liberty or something but the clerk's
example was the the second part is that
a contractor knows a guy is a mobster
and turns down a job to fix Roofing on
his house because he knows he's a
mobster whereas he could have just been
greedy and said yes he's going to pay me
twice I normally get I'll go to he said
no I'm not going to do it and that was
the the guy who overheard the
conversation interrupt saying you know
actually those people will take the job
in the Death Star
they should accept some responsibility
but I I I I'm sorry I just can't see
about working on the Death Star and
working in a bottle plant for projects
people did not know what they were
building nobody knew that that's the
famous story of how it was
compartmentalized and there were
theories about what it could or couldn't
be but no one really knew for sure once
you get to the Death Star and you look
around and see the uniforms the people
around you're not screaming these are
the bad guys you know your military
that's right the Empire The People the
average citizen in the Empire still
thought that they were living under the
the good guys the Republic yeah because
the the in the beginning of Star Wars
the of episode four like they say you
know we we just dissolved this the
Senate the imperious the last vestiges
of the Old Republic have have gone away
so people didn't really know that it was
the bad guys they were cheering for the
end of the Republic
existed yeah but are you not saying that
the name Death Star didn't kind of give
it away a little bit I don't imagine
that the average person
I don't think the people on Coruscant
called it the Death Star yeah like the
people working it's like we're building
a space station for the preserver it was
called the they probably called it like
the Republic still existed when they
were building it and they probably had
the Republicans commissioned a orbital
space station and I'm installing a laser
on it that can blow open until no you're
not installing a laser on to install the
laser who you're saying one guy built
the nuclear bomb one guy was like I'm
gonna build it myself you know if you're
building a laser maybe maybe some people
who worked in the Manhattan Project did
not know that but some of them didn't
the the highest like you you actually
had people like you know was it
Oppenheimer said I am become death yeah
some of these people knew exactly what
they were doing and said it but the
average person working on the project
had no idea so I'm saying this look Are
We Now defending the work the
contractors absolutely
defending them in this in this sense
well how can you defending them and not
the bottle plan no no just let me finish
okay I did defend the bottle plant
workers I am sad that they lost their
jobs I don't blame them for what Bud
Light did but I'm not going to cry that
they're no longer propping up the
banality of evil
the people work at the Death Star who
were killed in in by Luke Skywalker in
this this uh Terror campaign to blow up
a military base religious fundamental is
crazy religious fundamentalists on a
terror campaign military base call
whatever you want there there were
people who did not know what was going
on and like you said like some people
take responsibility for the things they
choose to do if you don't know that you
are providing a major component to a
weapon of mass destruction I'm not going
to be like well you know you're absolved
like over two and a half million
citizens of the Republic were on that
that space station and they all lost
their lives how can you how can you say
that that's okay how many civilian like
concerts or civilians but how many
civilians who weren't working there like
what about people's families you know
what I mean but anyway I digress in the
Star Wars point because it is a bit
silly the point is throughout history
there have been tyrannical regimes and
there have been soldiers who marched
along with those radical regimes doing
jobs that we would describe as mundane
filing paperwork or mopping floors but
these people still get how accountable
for being a part of these regimes that's
true but the people who mostly suffer
from these regimes of the people at the
very bottom with no say no agency at all
who get grinded up in the gears of
history and are forgotten and are turned
to dust
but that that's immaterial to like we
yes absolutely the idea that the the uh
uh I mean look there are Wars where the
the Kings or leaders of countries lose
and then say well you know actually I'll
give you an example from the Patriot Mel
Gibson love this movie when Mel Gibson
starts taking out the officers of the
British forces they that he actually has
a meeting with a guy and he's like we
want the cessation of you know the the
killing of officers and he goes no so
long as your officers are ordering the
targeting of women and children we I
will order my men to fire on them on
site the Cornwallis was like you you
can't Target the officers look we're
special people and he was like too bad
like it has always been the case that
the the Nobles will go to war and then
be like well you've bested me shall we
have a pint yeah people but look we're
not shooting the officers in this case
though we're shooting like the people
who are like way behind the lines maybe
working supplies or something like that
it's like imagine your imagine it's the
Civil War and there's a bunch of
Southern Confederates can scripted into
the war and they're marching on
Gettysburg and you're like no no don't
fire on them they don't know what
they're doing let them keep doing their
thing like bro they are the war yeah but
if you just shoot the generals and a
couple officers they'll go home back to
their Farms but that's not possible
because they're shielded not in this
case so the issue is the people at these
bottling plants are the ones who make
Bud Light the money and are are the ones
responsible for all of it I don't blame
them as individuals but I am not going
to cry that they lost their jobs we want
when we said I hope Bud Light goes out
of business did people like not realize
that meant they would lose their jobs
I just wanted the executives who made
the decisions to be fired and everything
that's ridiculous though but that's
never gonna happen but but otherwise
it's like you use the term collateral
damage
well look
um the last person to be fired is going
to be the people who are at the top I
hear you I hear you when the company is
a smoldering pile of economic figurative
Rubble then they'll be they'll they'll
be they'll only be fired because there's
no more money left not because anybody
fired them who fires the sea who fires
the boss the board the board and the CEO
are going to protect each other
depending I really doubt they're going
to go after him and it's the people who
build the machine this idea that it's
like
the machine the machine is made by the
individual laborers who all come
together in this big big swarm to make
Bud Light possible
so when we said that we hoped Bud Light
would go out of business or be knocked
down quite literally we're saying
thousands will lose their jobs
that's that's pretty rough but I hear
where you're coming from I just have a
point of disagreement with it yeah the
job economy thing is kind of like they
use it as an excuse to propel crappy my
position is the whole thing that
everyone has to have a job is like there
is no circumstance where our boycott
would lead to higher upset Bud Light
losing their jobs
the people made the decision lose their
jobs a couple of marketing VPS but the
person who actually made the decision
Melissa heiner said she's the one that
actually made this so so like one person
lost their job in the company doubled
down but it was one person's decision
ultimately so why is Bud Light still
sponsoring all these Pride events
I guess they need some more pressure and
all they did was do a PR stunt and
ignored the problem but now the machine
is actually crumbling and that means
when machine crumbles people who work on
the machine lose their jobs
yeah there's no circumstance where where
the highest of the company take
responsibility for this and anything
actually I mean look at the Santa's
campaign his supporters defend him when
he does things that are bad he won't
fire his press team it doesn't happen we
want there to be accountability but the
idea that like
it's it's it's just not the real world
the real world is that Bud Light is made
by individuals to the tens of thousands
the only way Bud Light stops getting
made is if those individuals stop
working to make Bud Light you can fire
the CEO they'll hire a new one you can
fire that Alyssa shot or whatever her
name is and they still keep sponsoring
if these people who quit their job they
just would have been replaced and
honestly these jobs are less than 10
years away from complete automation
anyway you're right they would be
replaced except if you get the plant to
shut down completely which happened well
they'll find another plant Capital will
find it no no no no no no they're not
finding another plant the plants shut
down because no one's buying the beer
and the bottles aren't going anywhere
where was the plant do you guys know
Louisiana the point is this
they didn't shut the plants down because
of cost they shut it down because nobody
is buying the beer you can't you can't
make product people won't buy it right
but your position is like if your work
at this plant you should have been
paying attention to social media and
caught way ahead of the outrage hey
they're about to release a can with a
transmission you had three months notice
afterwards when the boycott started to
start looking for work elsewhere it's
kind of like people that didn't know to
get their money out of the stock market
before the Great Depression like I have
compassion for those people but they
lost their money almost no one did
because they didn't know some people
yeah some people knew some people put
cash in their backyard some people
bought bought hard assets you know I do
not accept the argument that people are
not responsible for their own lives
I remember when I was a little kid I was
late to school one day because a train
came and when I got to school they
marked me late and I had to tell my
parents and get a form signed my dad
said why are you late and I said well it
wasn't my fault there was a train and he
said you know the train tracks are there
that's your fault you should have left
early to not get it stopped by the train
how old were you 13 would they have held
you to that account if you were five or
six
walking by myself you're talking about
47 40 year olds but again I guess
there's an age at which or there's
certain look yeah the guys the bottom
line is four years old yeah but the
bottom line is that
every American every person here I think
believes in Justice and when somebody
makes a bad decision that they're the
people that ultimately need to be held
accountable for it whereas people who
had no man they get home at the end of
the day they spend a little time with
their kids their wife they have a nice
maybe one beer and a nice dinner they're
not paying attention I'm glad they lost
their jobs all right well the idea that
you could ignore your Civic
responsibilities and not know what
you're building is is absurd to there
was one Cam that was issued as a
promotion and it blew up that is
incorrect
sponsored a contest okay drinking
several beers and put out of it was not
see this is this is the LIE the media
put out it was one promotional I can't
nothing no don't move any made a video
with a bunch of beers and it said
support this contest or something like
that and drank the beers and Dylan
Mulvaney said that they were hired by
Bud Light and then Bud Light basically
abandoned them
so so if the issue is Bud Light decided
to do this thing and it caused a
backlash and Bud Light refuses to
apologize doubles down on sponsoring
more of these events over and over again
where nude men are dancing and thrusting
in front of children which they did and
it keeps happening and you are working
at a plant that makes Bud Light and
you're like well I don't care I'm
getting paid I'm glad you got fired
every every person has a civic
responsibility the this is this is the
frustrating thing to me going to West
Virginia
86 percent supporting Trump and the
people there don't pay attention don't
vote don't organize they do nothing to a
certain extent I don't blame people for
not wanting to jump into this political
conflict but we need to recognize that
individuals have responsibility to their
country to their families to their
communities and it is being abandoned
too often by the right but the left
Revels in their cult-like behavior
that's why they had gained so much
ground so for Bud Light to do this and
for people to be like well it's been two
months but let's doubling down people
are mad sales are dropping every week we
can see I'm gonna keep working here
sorry I just I just don't think these
people had any awareness and it's
unreasonable too that's why it's their
expectation I I hear you look you are
technically right if you work for a
company and you just and they're doing
things that could cause you to lose your
job to be you should say yeah there's a
problem here I'm smart enough to
recognize I need to kind of get or I
have the options to or I but a lot of
these people they just so look
I have a jobs program at look ahead
America for people who have gotten out
of prison for j6 because they've got two
strikes against them they're they're
they've committed a crime they've
convicted but they also have the burden
of being a j6er right which makes it
even harder to employ them and we
promote uh we try to find employers to
place with them and we try to find
people that can uh uh that have suffered
from this who need help with employment
and we do that look at america.org jobs
for j6 so if you lost your job at this
plant in North Carolina we're going to
open up this program for you to do our
best to help you find a new job and if
you're an employer in North Carolina
please sign up to help us I'm going to
read one more Super Chat it's a good one
and then we're gonna go to the members
show at timcast.com phthalink says the
Empire didn't call it the Death Star it
was called project Stardust according to
Rogue one oh nice so we're going to uh
go to the members only show so smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com become a member
that's where the members show will be in
a few minutes you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast Matt do you want shout
anything out I do um look mostly
sometimes I agree with people largely
and they say something I disagree with
you just let it go but sometimes they
say something that's very dangerous and
recently Mike Lindell has done this and
he initially did it in a conversation
with I consider a good friend a great
Patriot Scott Pressler Scott Pressler is
advocating that we need an all of the
above strategy for voter turnout that we
need to encourage people to vote early
especially those who are not inclined
already to show up and vote on Election
Day and we see this happening again and
again and it's it's important that these
people have their voices heard and it's
affecting the outcome of Elections
whereas Mike Lindell may be best of
intentions but he's saying that no we
can't do that and he says you know these
people are 100 wrong he's quoted the New
York Times saying that we should only
have same-day voting should encourage
people to do anything else Mike I put my
head on your pillow every night to sleep
but you're wrong about this and I am
challenging you to a debate you name the
time the place I think maybe we can do
it here or on one of the other
Affiliated shows here at the the Tim Tim
cast world but I think you're wrong
about this and I think we need to have a
public discussion about that between you
and me and I I welcome you Anytime
Anyplace to discuss the importance of
this issue because it's going to have a
big impact and anytime Mike let's do it
we should have you guys on uh the
culture War I'd be happy to do it Mike
Lindell come on down to the culture War
podcast we'll get you guys we'll talk
about uh voting that'd be really fun
would be would love to do it we'll see
if we can make that happen that'd be
cool
I think it'd be fun I'm Phil Labonte
lead singer of All That Remains the band
is All That Remains uh on Instagram it's
all the remains uh on YouTube It's All
That Remains music uh Spotify Pandora
all that stuff and he is Matt Brainerd
on Twitter Matt Brainerd thanks for
coming man what's the name of your
organization again the job per day the
jobs website look ahead America and the
website is lookahoodamerica.org and uh
it's uh look at America
lookahadamerica.org jobs for j6 is it
the number four jobs four j6 uh spelled
out a good question for thanks jobs for
j6 and if you're a j6er and you're
having a hard time finding employment
because you got all these strikes we do
have employers that are willing to give
you a shot uh so let us we've hooked up
many people with employment and let us
help you thanks for coming ma'am great
to see you again also a special shout
out to conservative dads Ultra ripe beer
I had I think six of them over the
weekend although it was a long weekend
it might have been four or five it was a
lot and it was very good I don't
normally drink but when I do uh lately
I've been drinking Ultra right uh
conservative dad's Ultra right beer we
have it stocked in the fridge downstairs
uh and also I want to say goodbye have a
nice evening see you later
uh that was a good one thanks guys uh my
name is serge.com and remember guys it's
not about how hard you get hit it's
about hard you get hit and continue to
stand up and keep going so like you said
it's it's I feel bad for people losing
their jobs but you know people lose jobs
that's life but you have to get a new
job it's on you it's your responsibility
so I hope they can find work follow me
on the internet I made a threads thing
because I don't know it's not gonna win
it'll be done in a little while but
that's both Reds is out uh it came out
today so I made a stupid post saying are
you all ready for this or something just
because I wanted to make a joke well
let's go to the members only show so
head over to Tim com thanks for hanging
out we'll see y'all in a few minutes